yeah i think that's what it was you took
pcp though
the church of what's happening now is
presented by on it
this show is brought to you by naturebox
start snacking smarter with naturebox
naturebox recently made their service
even better than before now you can
order as much or as little as often as
you want with no minimum purchase go to
naturebox.com
joey right now to get half off that's 50
off of your first order when you go to
naturebox.com
joey
the show is also brought to you by
ziprecruiter with
ziprecruiter.com you can post your job
to 200 plus job sites including social
media networks like facebook and twitter
all with a single click
go to ziprecruiter.com right now
slash church to try it for free that's
right our listeners can try posting
their jobs for free on zip recruiter by
going to ziprecruiter.com
church
oh [ __ ]
i tossed some turn
monday february 20th
churchill what's happening now
proud to present my main man danny brown
without a frown that's right without
doubt
lisa
kick that mule that's right
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's how the stars make you
feel oh [ __ ]
it's on [ __ ]
what's going on you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey coming at you on a beautiful
monday night
post
my 54th birthday nice time at the store
nice weekend with the family went to the
school dance
how was that [ __ ] tremendous
high as [ __ ] i walked in there not
wreaking i ate edibles
i walked in there i had my hands in my
pocket i didn't bother nobody
to church you know the [ __ ] hoop
kids running around and awesome that
came over and he's like hey man listen
to the podcast what's going on
he goes i wish i had a flask right now
that's right
the next thing you know i started
talking to this dude that was an fbi
agent
he's married to a cuban chick
so my kid and up kid plays together
so i started my wife told me she goes if
he comes over
you know he's an fbi guy he can't
[ __ ]
say you got to be cool but i talked to
him for a long time he was cool both
went to the university of colorado
and everything was fine my daughter was
fine till the [ __ ] helium balloon
went to the ceiling uh-huh and that
little [ __ ] lost you understand my poor
little daughter just lost
my cheeks got red [ __ ] she was
yelling but you know what
7 30 she's done anyway she's done at 7
30. happy new year yeah
i grabbed her arm like she came over she
goes daddy and i touched her heart and
you could feel it about to go out of the
[ __ ] shirt
and her eyes like wiggling her cheeks
were red
she was [ __ ] going do you think they
just don't like it they get a little
overwhelmed they just don't know yeah i
don't know they don't know till they
stop
and they catch their breath
and then she had the balloon to balloon
the balloon once the whole [ __ ]
balloon went up to the ceiling and then
everything was good for about 20 minutes
but every five minutes you look at that
[ __ ] balloon
and you try to figure out a way how to
get the balloon
just took it home but it was great
i was in town and i had the opportunity
to do that with it yeah that's that's
the most important thing and i got gotta
tell you something man it was my the
best part of my week yeah all week i
waited for friday night for that [ __ ]
dances as dumb as it [ __ ] sounds no
that's not dumb at all like you said man
you don't do that type of [ __ ] she's
gonna be in the garage
with girls though i think that's the
most important thing about it's one
thing you know we have
boys but girls are like you know they
just look up to their dad way more than
any other man you know you set the trait
for whatever man they want to be with
everything in their life you know what
i'm saying
it's the blueprint it's going to start
with the day i'm saying so she follows
me guys she's she's at a different age
now where
in three or four months i won't be
smoking dope at the house no more yeah i
just know it because she watches my
hands she knows i go outside she shows
up
too much
they way smarter than we think they are
so i don't want her to smell it
i don't want her to see it that's the
thing about me from the time i remember
was man my mom smoked weed from the time
i already
met you
i remember just coming home from school
just loving that smell to be honest like
damn you make me hungry
you know it's so weird how moms have
changed how
how we judge our mom
maybe my mom did smoke weed
but she covered a lot of the bases that
people don't get covered today oh yeah
facts with their children a lot of
people don't cover those bases
my mom smoked weed and she covered
certain bases that
there's times on pistol for covering
those bases at that age
because it gives you that peak behind
the curtain yeah and the element of
surprise but
at the same time she covered a lot of
good bases that
and she smoked weed
you know she smoked weed i had a
godfather
who
really enjoyed weed you ever see a
[ __ ] who just smokes weed yeah
i'm tasman and that's a party for him
that's like pretty much my whole family
my whole family just we're pretty much a
drug dealer you know what i'm saying
like no drinking always did my i was a
crazy drinker you know what i'm saying
but she had to slow she got to slow down
now because she's starting to have like
you know trouble and [ __ ] but
for the most part my uncle i was like
dude heroin and [ __ ] like he was in
heaven since she's like 16.
you know so yeah daddy like
i don't know but smoking weed so that
was always like the less of anything
like what age do you remember seeing
people smoke weed
five yeah i can't yeah like i can't
remember tonight my godfather would pick
me up and tell me not even not smelling
it like it's always just my house just
smell like we all the time like no i'm
being like five and
going with my godfather to a movie
theater and before the movie would pull
over on the street
and you do the whole thing you get the
daily news
with the brown envelope but i'd be
sitting there going why is this
[ __ ] rolling his own cigarettes
he could just go to the [ __ ] store
and buy a pack you know
and then he would smoke it and from
being at my mom's bar i knew it wasn't
the cigarettes regular people smoking
you know you figure it out you know
that's me that's not that and then his
eyes would get red but he would get
really [ __ ] giggly and [ __ ]
at the time he was a spanish dude
that was probably in his early 30s his
spanish his english was very broken but
he always had like a white girlfriend
and after the movie theater we'd go back
to her house
and they'd smoke again like she'd be
giggling
you know it was the early it was the
late 60s early 70s everybody got hurt
so i'd go over there and they they'd
smoke again in front of me and they'd
get giggly
and i just make like a mental note don't
smoke that [ __ ]
because they'll make you [ __ ] giggly
you know
and then i would go home and see my mom
and my babysitter smoke oh [ __ ] what i
had
that's how i knew but i didn't say
nothing nobody like i didn't say no to
nobody
and then when you get to kindergarten
they take it to the police station in
new york
and they [ __ ] uh fingerprint you
no we didn't do that type of [ __ ]
extra
yeah like they got more i don't know
more phones to be able because i don't
remember that type of stuff that gives
you like a little badge to make you to
to to uh they do it to uh so you like
the cops right yeah so you like the cops
and they also shoot a gun and you get to
take the target
but it's funny i asked the [ __ ] cop
like
officer you know sometimes i'm walking
down the street and i smell funny stuff
and he was like that's marijuana so i
always knew
from the cop what my mother and my
godfather was smoking but i never said
nothing
it's not like i went out in the street
and said nothing until one day my mom
sat me down and she goes this is
marijuana mm-hmm it gets you [ __ ] up
i've never even had that conversation
yeah we have that conversation my
conversation came i remember when i
started smoking weed i feel like i
started smoking weed on the regular pike
or regularly probably around like 14 15.
so and i remember every time my mom's
probably didn't have wheat or something
and not coming house smelling like we
can see like
you better share that [ __ ]
so that's how we conversation started
dude yeah i just started smoking with my
mom in high school
like yeah about yeah i can't know about
you
i'm still cool
yeah my mom's living actually i just
bought her house actually though so
she's about to get ready to move she
don't know yet though she better get a
body there
where is she now i mean we still live in
michigan
why is she in a bad neighborhood no no
no we should live in me look at me in my
house i live in like you know like
you know
but what neighbor did you come from
originally no for me i came from um
linwood born and raised like west side
detroit then we moved to the east side
of detroit how was that
the west side of detroit to me i liked
it more because it was more about like i
think it's more like it was more like i
guess better it's more like suburban i
felt like
you know
like them and i moved to the east side
it was like gangs and [ __ ] like that you
know like the west side is all about
like you was the cool kid if you dress
nice
then you go to east side use the cool
kid if you knew how to fight you know
what i'm saying that's all it was about
so i don't know i mean i didn't really
like to fight too much
so i could take the east side you know
what i'm saying so i went back to the
west side
this is a stupid question i'm sorry but
the only thing i know about rap in
detroit is eight mile that's that's
amazing is what separates detroit from
the suburbs okay god so where's east
where's east and west like where's the
east i mean that's just in detroit in
general like the east side like it's the
east east eight mountain is a west eight
mile oh god so just east side and west
side you know what i'm saying so
but yeah the east side detroit is a
little more tougher they're a little
more like just grimier there's more blue
like the east side type of guys that had
like ten thousand dollars in their
pocket but look like a bum
you feel me and you meet a guy from the
west side he looked like a million
dollars and i got a penny
you feel me and that's just always with
the logic of it so i come from both
sides and i gained and learned a lot
from both sides a little bit to be
honest so it kind of molded me to be who
i am i'm kind of glad that i was able to
experience both sides of detroit because
i couldn't just imagine just living on
the west side all my life i wouldn't
have been tough a little because when i
moved to east side and then been through
all the [ __ ] i was going to come up with
beating me up and [ __ ] jumping on there
you know what i'm saying so by the time
i move back to the [ __ ] west
side i feel like them things were soft
like everybody was like you know this
felt a little soft and i wasn't really
just trying to be tough and i wanted to
dress and just be fresh like them too
you know just all about going shopping
and
you know we just always wanted to have a
new sneakers just go get the jordans you
know like [ __ ] like that
so
we didn't want to i didn't want to be on
that you know [ __ ] on the east side
was today was already breaking houses
and you know like someone was just like
middle school though like 14 15 i'm
saying because i went to elementary
school on the west side then my mom's
moved to the east side in middle school
and we moved over there like i said it
was like gangs and [ __ ] and
i don't know it was kind of weird
because i guess there was a phase in the
90s if you think about it once that
whole blood and [ __ ] [ __ ] probably like
went
because a lot of i bet you that [ __ ]
probably happened like in a lot of
different cities where it's like cause
that [ __ ] is like real out here that's
where origin at but then they was faking
it out there but people really lost
their lives and [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
because i remember it was like fake
bloods and crips and like two people got
killed dude it wasn't no more game
hanging out
crazy
they stopped getting out
that was not you can't find a bloody
[ __ ]
right let me simplify this because i
know you did some time
i knew nothing about that world
until i did time
and then when i started doing time
i became very tight with a [ __ ]
because at that time uh
the mid-80s
remember when that dude what's a
documentary of
the dude who brought coke into compton
um rick ross
whatever so
for some reason in those days the people
who are bringing coke to colorado to the
to the urban communities to black
communities in nevada and downtown
denver
with the crips
there's rumors that there was a
quarterback that played for the
buffaloes
and he was in college and he was like a
[ __ ]
so on the weekends he would drive to l.a
pick up coke yeah to bring to boulder
but this kid
that i did time with this toray kid we
became tight i mean we were in each
other's cells every night talking [ __ ]
stories yeah listen they're too short
you know
that's right
and it was very interesting
it was very interesting to me would i
join it
i was i'm not dead i'm not there but the
way he put it they would see that [ __ ]
was like they born into that born into
that so it's like your family like you
don't know nothing else type you know
this is what it is so i can say out
there it was fake but people really went
to jail or did dumb [ __ ] they probably
regret doing you know what i'm saying
people lost their lives
i remember that [ __ ] and it was kind of
wild over there for a minute you watch
those gang land shows
i love that [ __ ] i love it i love it
america's most
evil that's my favorite show right there
when you see those kids on msnbc
saturday late night you come back from
doing the show you scrolling through
your team watch them jail shows and [ __ ]
jail shows some of them be a little fake
to me you don't say something a little
weird do they really yeah some of them
seem weird because they're cause i i
could have missed them when i was in
jail i wouldn't and the camera came in
there i don't know how i would i don't i
mean i know you'd be so bored in there i
probably acted a goddamn food
well i mean they kind of do i mean and
just coming from like
i think about it i just had to have a
revelation i probably would act a
goddamn fool beautiful cuz you'd be so
goddamn bored you're just waiting on
anything i remember it was a point of
time like i was on one floor and you
could like look out the window to our
floor and you could see the girl prison
floor too
so we'd just look in the floor we just
show her titties and she'd be jerking
off in the window and she [ __ ]
got caught sent to the floors and [ __ ]
but you always wanted to go to that
floor where you could look and see the
[ __ ]
from your windshield it's like they are
in our county wayne county jail you
because it's like the female in the male
prison like right now each other
but if you can get on this one floor and
you can see this is one window
here right here
how much
let me ask you but i was the i was the
dumbest ever because i got how old were
you when you got arrested like maybe 19.
for my first case i call the
distribution in manufacturing the dummy
[ __ ] ever and that's crack no wait wait
i saw crack forever
that was the worst part of it and never
got in trouble we used to get
i sell and crack like like it started
for me like just you know just normal
[ __ ] like i said hanging out trying to
be cool just doing too much and just
caring more about
being fresh and actually caring about
clothes i mean and actually caring about
school and stuff you know
hey
so then i just i just hanging out with
the wrong crowd i guess i don't know i
can't say it's the wrong crowd because
you know you're just impressive boy as a
kid
were you like what was it like when you
went to prison like even when you just
found out joey said he was oh right
that's what i'm saying it was i said i
said i gotta get to this story to get to
that point you know what i'm saying so
with me it was like one day my homeboy
was just like
[ __ ] it you know he was he was he had
came into it you know some money so he
was trying to you know flip his money a
little bit you know like [ __ ] the school
[ __ ] i'm about to get some work and we
bout to about to put it down you want to
[ __ ] with me you want to do something
you know
so he got like this apartment building
you know what i'm saying and i was
terrified like i ain't you know i think
i was like maybe yeah i was like 17 18
maybe because you telling me pretty much
about i'm about to run my own outs
pretty much because you're not about to
be around you just putting the money up
to do it you kill me so i'm the one got
to sit there all the time you know so we
get the apartment you know end up
finding a place where the the landlord
was like a crackhead
so that's how we got the building in the
first place you know what i'm saying so
we got the apartment and it was slow for
maybe like a month maybe two months you
know and we maybe had like you know you
caught like a like an eighth like you
know like a you know just crack days
though you know so we got it cooked up
you know did the normal what we did
supposed to do slow not doing that but
we found this one crackhead named
chickenwing
you know and we call him chickenwing
because he just had a you know his hand
it was all [ __ ] up it's all [ __ ] up
you know what i'm saying so here
he would tell you know other crackheads
about and we just did a special three
for ten dime rocks you know just lost
out on like a batch cause we had it for
so long anyway so i [ __ ] did three
pretends just to get our name out there
and once we did that it just
took off empire like some [ __ ] i could
never even explain you cannot explain to
the point where i had to like grab other
kids from school like i had to go to
school because i was in there by myself
it was just me in there with a gun
and i remember one night you know i'm
just acting so long i got comfortable a
little bit i guess i mean one night
waking up late and i just you know woke
up and you know knock on the doors not
gonna disserving the lady and she and i
had the gun just right there like on the
table and she was like you better
you know you better watch yourself a
little bit you know i would sleep on the
floor you know she and i thought about
that though like damn she could have
just
picked that that pistol you know what
i'm saying took the whole [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
so ever since then i was a little more
tighter so then i ended up start going
back to school and [ __ ] and recruited a
couple more homies
and then we started off like that and we
ran that spot for about a good maybe two
years
like
two years selling crap like just
like me
they become no ideally they became
millionaires like we like me i never had
the
the mindset of a drug dealer i don't
think i never thought about that [ __ ] so
i was just getting my money and just
buying clothes and just spending it on
this random [ __ ] i didn't even realize
how much money i was even making to the
point when i recruited other
[ __ ] and i looked in two weeks
they was buying cars and putting rims on
them getting apartments and you know
what i'm saying i wouldn't even thinking
and i wasn't even thinking on that level
you know i was just spending my money
just you know partying all right so you
got an ounce of coke 28 grams
you paid 800 for it how do we make it
750 yeah yeah sorry 750. let's just say
800.
we put it i usually chop up 1200. so i
chop up 1200 in stones
which i'm ounce of crack
all right let's say we have an ounce of
coke
you got to go get it cooked you want to
just cook it so you got to find a
special cook which was like me i [ __ ]
with my uncle but he's my homie he's the
[ __ ] there's one dude it needs to so
you want the special guy who could bring
your [ __ ] back a little extra you know
you know backwards could bring some
extras right sometimes trying to bring
it back extra end up [ __ ] up the
whole batch right because i remember so
many times having the [ __ ] up batch
and that [ __ ] slow you can't get
that [ __ ] i mean one time we asked the
[ __ ] um he left he had the coke
in his girl purse and it was around her
perfume
and it the perfume is something
absorbing the coke and then when he
cooked it up
it was [ __ ] up when we were trying to
say calling that [ __ ] michael jordan
cologne because that's when the michael
jordan clown just
we got an ounce of powder which is 28
grams what am i looking for to get back
from that
when i'm in the crack world and the
crackers like i said with me
if breaking it down telling you all you
got is an ounce you ain't you can't do
nothing but try to sell that in the
stones he's gonna sell eight bars you
know what i'm saying no no but i would
take it
all right i had a buddy
i had a buddy who i give him
8 500 bucks
and he give me back 11. ounces of coke
that was beautiful [ __ ] beautiful
we take one ounce out of the gold
and we throw a [ __ ] four in there
and he'd do this [ __ ] thing
and he put it in the oven
and it was still an inch he called it
re-rocking it yeah yeah and he would
take an inch it was an inch thick
and then we would break it and he'd take
the walls off
and that's what we would snort like
[ __ ] around the wall so they wouldn't
see the walls on it
and
if you picked up the rocks you could
still see the shine yeah
so that was his chemical breakdown for
it was still great coke it was great
coke nobody knew i would take it to
colorado
but i had friends who were in the crack
business and they told me they would get
a paint can
and put four ounces of coke in there and
put
turpentine this is this is 85.
it
like
this is the [ __ ] they were serving up in
85 okay okay and you get four ounces or
two ounces of that
crack and you break it up into
you know ten dollar stones mm-hmm yeah
and he'd make you know three thousand a
day off
[ __ ] crazy that's what it was with me
i was getting like i said me i get at my
max because it started off with just me
getting a ball
you know i'm saying i get eight bar
which i think would you give me three
and a half yeah so
i supposed to give my honey back you
know what i'm saying so i'll chop up 15.
so 150 make a 50 off it usually we try
to double but we want the biggest zones
because it was more apartments in that
building i told you the landlord was a
crackhead right
so if he gave me a ball and he it was it
was i had to give chop up 15 songs i'll
give him and i was probably like i said
we was i remember one time i could like
like somebody got knocked on a dog
because we had two we even got to the
point we had two apartments like
apartment building across from each
other and we kept the work in that one
and we did we do that
and i remember just going in the hallway
and in that time like set on like three
eight balls and stones
like before they even chopped up like
just
before i even went back into the other
one just for [ __ ] coming in the
hallway that's how crazy this was like
late 90s so like 98.99 that'd be the end
of the cracker though because no one i
feel like there's no new crackheads now
like no one just digs right down
85 in new york city you make a
a right turn off of main street let me
give you an example let's say you were
driving on broadway
on
181st street
and you made a right turn within two
blocks
two blocks like within a block you'd see
[ __ ] on the corner just looking
at you and they're the ones that don't
tell you nothing they want you to come
up to them and ask them for directions
then you go where you're looking for and
they're like i'm looking to get high
what do you need i got it right now
but if you went down another block the
more you went away from that you looked
at the savages oh yeah lee they're the
ones that run up to your car
and hold your [ __ ] your rear view
mirror
what's up what's up what's up what's up
what's up
let me get [ __ ] two ounces of
coke yo flocco khan over here that was
right let me see the cash you ain't a
cop right no i ain't a cop let's do this
[ __ ] bam when you come on the block from
now on ask for danny b that was here all
day from 12 to 12. lee it was a business
that was being run on the street and
there was ten [ __ ] on the same
street fighting for the same nickel and
guess what
they would all go home with pockets fat
and did the cops just not care do they
not know are they i mean
they know you play that game and just
play the game they coming they're gonna
come one day you're going one one day
one day you're gonna be there one day
it's just a part of the game
you know see but it's not a game though
you know you're not that's not you don't
you're not thinking about that like that
was just not nothing just thinking about
the money you're not you're not even
there anymore danny and i'm worried for
you
like it just that's no i'm so away from
that life oh no no i'm away from i'm
just 36 years old about to be in march
you know what i'm saying so i'm so far
that we talking about 98.99 like back in
that like
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] but anyway like
that [ __ ] got [ __ ] over like you're
saying we end up being those savages on
the block cause we ain't had that
apartment no matter what those savages
were getting flea those guys
never had dick
and now they're giving them an
opportunity to make 300 cash a day
they don't even go home
those dudes don't even go home because
they ain't nothing at home but a fan and
a floor why go home really stay out here
off yes yeah that's how it is you don't
go home because you might miss the white
dude
that comes over there
that comes over
to get coke for his whole neighborhood
or weave his home
right because then after wow you become
the guy
i don't like i don't like going into the
city i'm scared okay no problem those 20
bags you like they became 40
because now you're going into the city
league you became friends with danny
yeah and as soon as danny sees you on
the block you page him before you come
over he's out there waiting for you what
is it about guess what
nobody will say a [ __ ] word to you on
that street nobody will try to rob you
on that street
no you'll get if you have a lot on you
something you'll get in the car follow
you to that [ __ ] bridge
it's amazing how much they protect you
because you are their livelihood mm-hmm
danny's not gonna call me and go joey
wait on the corner for a volkswagen with
a sure little jew in there and hit him
in the head with a stick and take those
drugs there's no money in that
they want you to keep coming back it's
such a weird
it's obvious
it's [ __ ] it's this is all it is
there's no other way to break it down
what we did in 85 but the [ __ ] the part
about it is that like me like i say
all that savage like i didn't ever get
caught no trouble like he said the
police i didn't go to jail for that i
went to jail for weed that's good that's
what got me locked up with selling weed
but let me tell you why because when you
sell crack it's so sketchy and so you
know it's a real world we know what
you're dealing with when you [ __ ]
with that type of [ __ ] you know you know
what you know what you're involved with
with weed it's your homies
this league is he trying to come over
here and buy a bag you know they pulling
up the music loud
you know what i'm saying everybody
they're coming over wild time you know
crack it's discreet everything was
even though we had this apartment
building it was still like even when we
used to get ready it was a time we was
getting raided like two times a week but
no one would never get caught because
they had to get buzzed in to get into
the apartment building
and who else can buzz them in but a
crackhead or a personal selling crack
so once they come they lease out there
five minutes before they even get in to
even try to break the door because the
door was so it was like not that type of
door you can hit with the [ __ ] and it's
going to open and we would just run
straight up we would just leave out the
apartment run straight on the roof and
go out like the chimney and just sit on
top of the chimney you couldn't you
couldn't get ups weird really ounce of
wheat up there we just go up there
roll some blush up smoke today league
come back down
pay a crack he had to clean the
[ __ ] up
back open his next night back up in a
few hours you feel the plan
that was the rule that was that was the
way it was
it was fun though i
but see i used to go down blocks that
were [ __ ] savages
like in like in
the late
80s in new york
cuban refugees
when those mariolitos came you didn't
know they were black or [ __ ] cuban
and they would sit on that street and
run after you but when i got to san
francisco the cubans were selling wheat
on
coke and wheat on the street
and i told them i said guys you're going
to get nailed every [ __ ] day
go down the corner and put a dice game
up here
for the dice game up there they looked
at me all weird the same way
that's like bringing more heat right i'd
rather them stop for the dice game
by the time the dice game is getting
broken up the coke dude is running down
the corner uncle joey you see that's
right
was one of those cuban dudes that saw a
coke
that used to be married with kids
but in when he went to jail he became
part of that lifestyle where you just
[ __ ] men
and they suck your dick but you don't
you don't let them [ __ ] you
so he was a cuban dude that would be
well dressed and he'd have two dudes
with wigs on and makeup and [ __ ]
and that was his appointment operation
so i would tell him to hide the coke in
the bumpers
right listen to me
you know i'm the real dear holyfield and
he would smack them and their wig would
fall off the street
like he was domestic
it was 1985. you get domestic violence
whoever you wanted
he was domestic violence seeing these
half of [ __ ] he would smack them
open-handed like if they brought the
wrong leg domestic violence because you
can't be smacking people like that you
got a wig
it counts for something
and in those days there we go
in those days there were no lbgt
community no he was just smacking him
sorry like me would just smack them in
the street if they [ __ ] anything up
anything and they would be there with
him there would be like two guys dressed
up as women
and they would be side by side and he'd
be slaying coke
and nobody would say dictum because he
was one of those mariolitos the ones
that came
in 1980 with scarface those crazy
[ __ ] so would you see them
around like around town just with the
black eyes
like would you see them beat up around
town all the time he would choke him in
public oh my god he would do the
weirdest [ __ ] kicks
what was they doing for him he he had an
apartment where they both lived
and he would take him up in the daytime
and give him dick
pay for the bills
and they would hide his drugs everybody
knew that his drugs were hidden upstairs
in these two gay dudes apartment
this was [ __ ] nuts
this was [ __ ] the street of nuts
but i bet i i could in some sense
but i bet you they could hold water more
than a female in that certain situation
i could trust a man to hold my work
instead of a woman he would travel with
them too he would take him to miami to
pick up the blow
he would travel with them like they were
[ __ ] that was his logic i'm trying to
take him out you know it's [ __ ] crazy
when you walked in here you said
something
and i've been dying to ask you what is a
[ __ ] mixtape
that's how [ __ ] old
okay okay
break it down for uncle joey what's a
mixtape see in our i guess a mixtape
would just be
a and back in the day it would be you
would take other people's beats
it's just freestyle over them because
you couldn't you didn't have
that good of production as accessible to
you
you know so you've taken whatever the
top industry beats is and if you can do
it as good as
an industry rapper at that point it will
show how good you is you know so making
a mixtape was a good point to show how
good he was in the rapper like maybe
early 2000s
leaving me a favor play opp for a second
you going with opp i just gotta ask you
a question
i just want to learn something trench
naughty by nature
i just went to uh when i go to edgewater
and i stay in edgewater when i go to
jersey mm-hmm
yeah
jersey right there yeah i see him matt
yeah
well he don't live in the hood no more
he was in edgewater what what what
now who is he paying
other people's property
this song is talking about [ __ ] other
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh no no no i'm not
talking about that oh i hit michael
jackson's oh oh oh is this a mixtape
right here no this is an album no this
is no i know this is a budget they had
to clear that sample
[Music]
for that [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] money
that's why that song was a big hit
they paid it but i bet you never made i
bet he probably even make no money off
this song
that's a commercial that's what i call
them when you use a [ __ ] sample that
is so expensive that you're not even
gonna be able to clear no money or even
like if you use a like
like like me like with my last album i
like use the part from from jay-z and
kanye's song
on dip where i say don't let me enter my
zone
and just off that alone i don't even own
that record no more
they um they make more money off that
record than i i could
like you know what i'm saying just from
using that little part
and there's an idea or like the dip part
that was like a dj
nasty part from atlanta like you can't
do it like that's why i never would do
that [ __ ] ever okay so
is that a mixtape right there opp no
that's from the album that's from the
debut album actually that was the first
single from the album but reach out my
mixtapes became popular probably like
two thousand early two thousand right so
a mixed table well at first the mixtape
was from djs that was dj's just finding
the exclusive
records from top rappers to the point
where like they were still in records
like back in like let's say
mid 90s early 90s to
late 90s you know what i'm saying that
was when the mixtape in new york that
was the mixtape scene was cracking
because i remember like if a
[ __ ] went to new york and came
back with like a dj clue mixtape
and they were you know what i'm saying
come back and you hear that [ __ ] it
would have [ __ ] on there that you could
never because before the internet
so that was how you heard [ __ ] you would
never because i guess hearing demo
versions because sometimes you would
hear a song and you would end up hearing
the real version of that song when adam
came out and it wasn't it was like damn
you're two different worlds he was like
damn i liked it the mixtape version
better
so i guess in the demo version or
sometimes just hearing like i guess
exclusive sometimes people leaking
records to the dj giving them because
that dj that hot at that point
you know what i'm saying like a dj back
in the day it was like dj clue
you know then you know it was a thousand
degrees i remember i'm a producer i'm in
my basement
i come up with a [ __ ] cigarette
i put it on a mix i put it on a [ __ ]
uh yeah you get a dj i give it to a dj
at a club it just so happens just
chilling with wiz khalifa you hear that
beat and you go
whose beat is that
i want that b you go up to the dj who
gets paid here nobody gets at this point
ain't no money in rap music i really
feel like so this this tape i just made
mine no all that is free you don't give
me all that time nothing nothing with
mixed safe i'm talking all free world
i mean you're using other people music
no this is my music i know like
basically like with me my first album
that that they could that you considered
to be my first album which was triple x
which you know
it was considered to be a mixtape when
it came out because it was free but it
was an album to me when i was making it
i was making an album you know i had
just signed my first deal with an indie
label foosgold so i was making an album
i wasn't thinking about making a mixtape
who paid you they i mean they signed me
when i signed i got you know i got a
signing bonus and that's it that's it i
didn't even get a budget for this record
but that record
i didn't even have a budget crazy
[ __ ] world bro like i had a friend
that just was cool enough to just like
he ran he worked at a studio
and if i just pay him
like a good good ass studio if i just
pay him then he would stay late hours
and just let me record so i would have
to go to his studio maybe like
two in the morning and record all the
way to six so i recorded that album that
i'm talking about like four sessions
maybe like you know
like mix and master everything boom
turned in because
i mean i wrote it for them in like a
year though like like like that's why i
i [ __ ]
i [ __ ] relate to comedy so much in
some sense because i'm more of a writer
i think than anything i just rap because
i think that was just what i was around
but i think the writing part is what i
love the most you know just being up
late night and writing some [ __ ] and
just
singing it to myself like this some [ __ ]
and then once i recorded and put it out
and then seeing all the you know the
reviews and [ __ ] i get back and be like
oh yeah i was right you know i knew all
that hard work i put in writing and
[ __ ] every night sitting with this
[ __ ] rewriting
recording it re-recording you know so i
like the writing part because i hate
sitting in the studio that's the one
part i hate them now who comes up with
the with the beats with me i have a
producer in london that i work with a
lot that i connect with his name paul
white i work with him since but since
like
yeah for like the last xxx and like you
know so that's like my main producer i
work with other than that i try to work
with like producers at this point that i
always wanted to work with so i reach
out to like all the old school guys
there like i want to
i would love to work with rizza from the
wu tang you know what i'm saying at this
point so i'm just trying to get with all
the producers that i always wanted to
work with at this point but at this
point like yeah put it i worked with
paul white as a guy in london but he
pretty much like he was more into like
he into a lot of the psychedelic [ __ ]
that i was into
and that's why i connect with him like
because he just it's like a lot of live
instrumentation you know what i'm saying
type [ __ ] so it ain't just a
[ __ ] just sampling you know it's
like we
i don't know we're really trying to like
be progressive with rap at this point
who are your influences
with rap or
in general in general music yeah like in
general
man i would say like [ __ ]
like nice as rap like rap music
tremendous and i was like
that's what i always like looked up to
because i just looked at that like
the great
story of like i don't know of what a
rapper is supposed to be like
i always say like a rapper can't be made
like every day a [ __ ] say i want
to be a rapper i never had that
conversation with myself
rappers are born you know i'm saying i
was in kindergarten and they i was in
show-and-tell i had nothing to show or
tell i ain't know
and i just said a wrap randomly and the
class was lit the class was like that
[ __ ] was dope
can i ask you a question danny i was
thinking about this and it's
i just can't rap it that's weird that's
why i started rapping kindergarten
like i was thinking about this the other
day
a lot of like musicians and like when
you think of guys you don't really think
of singing being like a very like manly
activity and i know rapping isn't
technically really always singing
but like i don't know is it is it like
tough is it manly to be a singer
like some of the best singers weren't
even good singers though okay yeah you
feel me
like some of my favorite artists i don't
think like in that world like i don't
think ian curtis was a great singer like
from jewelry division i love georgia
[ __ ] unless they were my favorite bands
so that's one of my biggest influences
that's actually my last album was just
like really like influenced and like
really like
i guess like attributed to him in some
sense i called it atrocity exhibition
because that first song of that closer
album like i really just hit home with
me really hard you know so i just took
that one song and made a whole album out
of it who was the crack cat from the
temptation the crackies
david ruffin that's he's got a great
voice yeah now that's that's a real
thing when he went
that's my favorite temptations anything
it is very masculine to sing late it is
you feel [ __ ] yeah
well exactly
i mean it's monday we're going to play
tony bennett here in a minute and tony
that's only been it for decades has been
doing it but i was thinking about it the
other day it's like
you both joey is like especially you're
you're very much like a man like you
like men's men like tough things and
then just singing just seems a little
bit apart from that
but not not like you're like a wimp but
it just i don't like it for a second it
doesn't really click up you ever heard
those narco songs yeah that's what i'm
saying you hear them [ __ ] singing dude
you going [ __ ] 7-eleven you hear some
mexican music playing and they just
sound like they just playing some
[ __ ]
margarita music or something and they
really talking about chopping heads off
and killing people
that's true yeah that's like the
craziest thing in the world
expression
has been around you know i love these
people like right now you showed up
tonight you showed up with
five of the greatest classic rap albums
involved yeah you know how to come
through it you know but it's like i'm
the [ __ ] that
tells you that no rap's been around for
a long time that
put on
something fell well the album finally
went fine put on patato
and totico
okay this is this is wrapping cuba in
1960
okay
tell me what songs are available
all right hold on
how did you even know what he said like
no because i've heard we've been
i grew up on this uh
you like this one agua cake vodka no no
uh and el cajon
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the one
he just
he's talking over conga drums
okay this sounds like narcos already
yeah he's
i'm still waiting for somebody to buy
the rights to this
and rap over this
i mean it's easy carl
and he was talking some gangster [ __ ]
he's talking about his [ __ ]
neighborhood though
he's talking about hilda
and hilda told him
i was out doing my [ __ ] thing
just the translation
poteet
now i have definitely checked this out
it's just a basin car in bongos
andy garcia paid for the base plan to
get out of cuba
this is this is like when you go to a
cubans house and you look at their
record collection if you don't have this
you just get up and leave it
because this is the heart of cuba this
is this is put on
i swear to god this is what the nyani
girls used to play for that
that is the type of [ __ ] that i like to
rap to oh this is the [ __ ] somebody
needs to wrap like minimal [ __ ] this is
this is this is something that
this album that i play all the time on
here
[Music]
this is
this was the beginning of mumble rap
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is [ __ ] too much
this is too much that's experimenting at
its finest that this is 1960 something
there's one jam off that first down that
he's [ __ ] and this was huge this was
huge for cuba this is like
huge
in the afro-cuban community
that's the other community of cuba you
have three different types of cubans you
have the light-skinned ones
you have the tragenos were mixed with
the indians that columbus killed
and then you got [ __ ] that look
like danny brown
and that's just the way it is in cuba
now the [ __ ] that look like
danny brown that just didn't
pop up on an island thanks they were the
slaves they brought over that stayed
and they had this [ __ ] language and
they had this whole thing going on
and that's why it's called afro-cuban
okay
because it's very african they just put
a little cuban on top of it
and this [ __ ] will go this is like
afrobeat [ __ ] too yeah hence a lady
called sally cruz mm-hmm that's
afro-cuban play uh kimba can bottle
phone
that one i can't type danielle yeah you
can't just personally cruise it'll be
the one the song exactly
right this is afro-cuban and it's so
weird when i listen to that type what is
it called that's like rap music for you
this is rap music for cuban people now
they have their own 60s yeah everybody
now they have their own rap music in
cuba it's called celia cruz right and it
begins with a queue kimbara yeah
who the [ __ ] is this
5 46 in the morning crack at dawn and
you know i mean
this is black african music in cuba
24 million views
oh no
see when she signed
if you watch the
the series on [ __ ]
netflix netflix the first when she
signed with the first label they were
throwing cuban music out
and they're like it ain't working and
some guy in new york said doug
we gotta you gotta call her blood you
gotta tap into her blood
and that was the rest is history damn
you got to tap into what the [ __ ] you
are bro
this ain't no club that this ain't no
rap music you shut this stuff up
i like both i know that's tremendous
that's even my wife likes that album
that's a great album
that's like a [ __ ] great album right
there now dan like danny if do you go
and tell your guy in london like i want
something like this or this or is he
just like does he just send you
how it started even how it started it's
just email it's just email he'd make
beats at home and just send him
and that's pretty much how i started he
started sending me beats in like 2 000
team
and i just remember just getting a
random email you know you know what it
is you know you had your twitter you had
your whatever and you had your [ __ ]
email out and i just had an email to
send you know
and you just sent some beats to me one
day i just opened them up and i'm like
[ __ ]
they were really good so i just hit him
back and just
you just kept just started working ever
since and that was just 2017
what the [ __ ] listen let's let's get the
[ __ ] elephant out of the room
my blood is music yeah effects i just
the drugs
i knew
that i could never have the commitment i
needed for music look at drugs i was
doing it it's like drugs and music go
hand in hand not this level of drugs
i'd be housing things you know you don't
need that
who's here last year first off you know
you got 20 black dudes in your studio
and i'm the thief oh you know
just wouldn't go off well
with 20 [ __ ] in here and the
white dude is the fight bro i would
steal these chairs when i was snorting i
was snorting how are you gonna steal
chairs i just knew that i would pawn
like you know
you stole everything in the studio
everything in the studio
everything i say i think i don't know i
think it really just with me and music
like i look like i like you i love music
i'm a fan more than i think i am
the artist of it you put up the music at
the house every side my dad was more
into house music
that's crazy
what's happening music house music is
like just like you know like dance music
like check like detroit techno like
ghetto tech like [ __ ] like that just
that was my life moms is that where is
that where you had young parents that's
what happened my mom's was 18 my dad was
16
when i was born grandma grandparents you
never go over there my grandparents my
my
my dad's mom is filipino
so that's that whole world okay so i got
that filipino world and then my mom's is
black so yeah my grandpa my grandmother
still living but i never had i never met
my grandpop's none of my granddads and
nothing like that
there's never really a lot of men in my
family
i had one uncle who was in jail all the
time and then i had another uncle who
was my um auntie's boyfriend my mom's
older sister
and he's pretty much like he's been more
influential like far as like
than probably anybody in my life to be
honest you know my dad's like i said he
had me at 16. jesus so yeah
he had four kids like and he had three
kids back to back like my dad was a
criminal i think about it every like i
think about all the time like he was
really kind of like he's crazy with like
sixteen and twenty he had a kid six
years he had 16 17 18 then he stopped
the year didn't have one at 19. so about
20 you have four kids [ __ ]
different [ __ ] world my friend
let's imagine being ready
different [ __ ] world my friends
you know yeah
when i listen to your music alright
first off we came in here one day [ __ ]
some dude danny brown wants to be on the
podcast
i thought it was a white dude
so for a month people are gonna get
danny brown on there
i kept thinking danny brown was the
white dude rogan had on that smoked
joints at the joint after joint
blood had to blood at the blood what's
the white dude though
do you want me to say it
don't worry about it don't say it yeah
that's a white guy i didn't know
he comes in here papa papa papa papa
danny brown danny brown danny brown
listen
if i want eminem i'll [ __ ] call him
all right
i thought it was a white dude if i want
eminem i'll send him a [ __ ] telegram
all right
so i go home one night i'm stoned to the
[ __ ]
he's loyal about weird things right
and
yeah i don't need no white rat
first of all i invented the white rapper
in 1985.
you're looking at him right here joey
diaz invented the right rapper at the
sheridan on 52nd and [ __ ] seventh i
broke it down for this black dude and a
white dude that were from a record label
i was bartending and i said to listen
the
[ __ ] uh
uh you know
the two guys in brooklyn
who the two guys in brooklyn 85 uh
beastly boys no
way before the beastie boys
i said i told the other dudes [ __ ]
snap pop crap golem pop
what's his name uh
come on my adidas oh run dmc run dmc i
go listen run dmc is
great and grand master flash is great
all that [ __ ] is great
but you guys got to get a white dude
a white dude but the beast the beastie
boys the beastie boys came out maybe two
years later yeah i swear to god on my c
she's a [ __ ] genius see see i'm a
[ __ ] even now like with that's what
i'm saying rap music now i feel like
it's like so oversaturated
i can't even see how people make money
in it at this point there's so many
rappers like it's just
especially with the internet which is a
great thing to be honest because it's a
great thing yeah can i i saw a video
about this other this rapper yesterday
and i just
it blew my mind there's this guy chance
the rapper yeah i don't really i don't
know anything about him just ever since
i got into podcasting i don't listen to
music anymore i just wanted grammys man
i'm not huge he was on the grammys he
did for the white house
saturday night twice and he doesn't he
heard any of his music he don't have a
record dude he he so what does he just
he did his own festival where like fifty
thousand people came
and he also so he just charges for that
stuff just internet that's crazy it's a
whole new world you know i still come
from that era like i said i've been
trying to do it since the late 90s
so i come from that whole different era
you know of how to do it and but these
kids yeah it's a whole different world
with them
like me like i always wanted to be on an
independent label kind of because i knew
i couldn't like i had a freedom i wanted
to do with my music that i couldn't do
on a major label
like being assigned to like i i couldn't
make the
girl songs or the clubs like you got to
think the music business is exactly what
it is it's the music business but i
didn't realize that until
now i'm kind of got deep in it and it's
like [ __ ] nobody knows when you get a
mortgage once you get a mortgage and
you're like [ __ ] you know the business
side of it will put you into shock yeah
because guys like you and i started just
to get out of what we were doing
yeah regularly
one point in time in my life i was like
if i could just be able to just support
my weed habit and
buy fresh clothes and i'm good
i'm happy with that i swear
i thought i was going to travel all the
time i wasn't going to get a residence
i was going to get like a down point
like live with four dudes
my plan was to travel 40 weeks a year no
kids no wife
no family and just do comedy
but see now with this chance guy
and guys like yourself with the internet
so your music is free
but you charge on the road yeah that's
pretty much get paid that's it you get
paid for your show that's it but you
know how that is though we think about
the level of those guys though like like
they didn't even like they were just
getting millions of dollars off of their
music like we're not making no money off
music the music is the commercial that's
why i call it the commercial right now
you're selling everything else that's
why me i'm trying to get more
into doing anything else like rap to me
i'm trying to make it more of a hobby
and just starting to try to you know
it's of course it's my number one job
but it was my hobby before and that's
when i loved it and that's when i felt
like i could do my best at it
i don't want to ever look at it to the
point where i know that it's paying my
bills so i got to do what i got to do
with it you know and sacrifice the art
or make [ __ ] that i don't really want to
make just because i know to make some
money
just because i need that to pay my bills
you know so i'm trying to just do more
[ __ ] like i've been getting more into
like voice over like just trying to do
like you know like cartoons and [ __ ]
always been
just wanting to get into that you know
i think you're always rap
of course that's what i'm driving on the
[ __ ] street down there's a billboard
of ice cube about to beat up a white
dude
you know fist fight like i need to watch
this movie i know lee can't wait for it
to happen
him and his girlfriend are going to go
because they like that guy that's going
to park some wreck and he's
here that
even though i'm looking at ice cube
and i'm looking at this thing all you
think about is ice cubes i'm thinking
about tadao how you like me now i'm in
the mix you can't it's 1986 and i got
that you know what i'm saying but that's
the point that's all i'm saying
there's so many avenues now where you
can make
a living but you're still gonna you're a
rap what it makes you do in a way
is that now when you go back to rap
the intensity even with myself let's
pretend tamar only they come to me and
they gotta shoot a movie for eight
months and you can't do stand-up
you know what after a month i'm gonna be
happy but i'm gonna be sad i'm gonna
start writing
and i'm gonna write the best [ __ ]
it's so hard with rap music though man
it's really sometimes really depressing
to be honest because you can like me a
person i spend
two years three years to make an album i
would never
i would never receive the money
or anything that i could get back from
rap music that i put into that that i
made like other back in the day like
maybe
everybody else could probably see the
return like nowadays some kid could just
make one random song on soundcloud
and now he's you know winning the grammy
tomorrow do you feel what i'm saying
so it's almost like it's a whole new
like i said it's a whole new world you
can't really it's like a new ball game
like i feel like and i'm i'm still
playing by all rules kind of
you know
i mean well somewhere along the line you
could play with old rules
but like new way of thinking mm-hmm you
know
listen i i see a lot of comics my age
that i'm at home
yeah
you know i could i could have been at
home tonight my daughter too facts i
know kids i don't know
but
same here i want to be with my cats
at the cats i want my voice to be heard
we want to get out there
you know this is our commercial yeah
this is leonardo's commercial he wants
to do consulting
i want to do stand-up this is a [ __ ]
commercial somewhere along the line you
got to sacrifice
but it's not a bad sacrifice no not at
all because 20 years ago you didn't have
this
opportunity no because 30 years ago you
didn't have this the way i look at this
is american dream you want to be able to
support yourself of something you love
doing
nothing sucks more than like we said i
was a [ __ ] selling crack i didn't
want to do that [ __ ]
i just wanted some jordans you feel what
i'm saying
like so
and i was to the point where
yeah
i'm comfortable in life but it sucks
when
you see like i don't know you see like
certain
certain music i don't know like half a
noun type stuff it's almost like i don't
know like robbing a bank
years ago i feel like it's like rapping
banks sometimes with the way people make
music sometimes because they know what
they're doing because they're that
talented
they're that talented that they can make
something that they can program with you
to like like they know it they know it
sucks to their self that they wear your
mortality but they know this is what the
people like when your boy and the other
guy stole that song from marvin gaye
you're a boy
boy he ain't my boy why is my boy what's
that dude's name right here robin i
didn't know i was stealing the song i
was on pain medication ramen rabbit
thick i will smack you the [ __ ] death
the first time i heard that song i said
that's marvin gaye
i said that to myself in a [ __ ] car
that's marvin [ __ ]
the other poor little bastard i don't
know i never heard that song but how the
[ __ ] did you not hear that song you grew
up in a black house who the [ __ ] you
think you're talking to that's what i'm
saying it's the same thing like if
somebody stole a joke oh please it's a
[ __ ] nightmare it's the same thing
like but it happens all the time i think
more with music though
people just it's like a trend to just
like back in the day like we're like
wu-tang when the [ __ ] around
you came out and tried to rap like
wu-tang wu-tang might [ __ ] you up
nowadays it's just cool to just sound
like whatever's hot like let's just say
whoever the high rapper is everybody
that just trying to rap this sound like
him it's like no more originality i
think that's what the internet kind of
[ __ ] up though because i remember time
my life where we just had these albums
going about tapes and going about [ __ ]
in the ghetto boys didn't look like dr
dre and dr dre didn't look like wu-tang
and but nowadays you look at every
rapper they all look the same
hey we got the hold on
everybody's cold
they could be a [ __ ] florida and they
got a [ __ ] hood
yeah a real cap on and [ __ ]
god forbid they don't have to go t the
[ __ ] you know
everybody looks to say what is it lee
what's going on well like what at what
point is that allowed like the that
amount of of sampling because just for
example what sampling is all about
what happens is
let's just say i take like you say okay
this is what could happen with that with
that k with the michael jackson record
let's just say
i sampled the michael jackson record
right
and i want to get it clear but then they
say [ __ ] for you to use that it costs a
million dollars [ __ ] i can't afford a
million dollars
to pay for that michael jackson sample
so i take it and i get it replayed and
you will go find people who can replay
this you find a band you find some
players or you get it piece by piece
there's a bass on there it was a piano
you find instruments and you
find musicians that can replay this and
then you can just use that because you
don't have to clear that because you
replayed it
really and that's how i mean but it
sucks kind of when you do that it's
never the same as what it was with the
sample
like my last album oh
i i was a lot of replays and the replays
is never as good like i wish people
sometimes i'd be wanting people to hear
the original demos of some of these
songs that we replayed like if you hit
the actual [ __ ] it was phenomenal i mean
it came out still
i mean i did the best what i could
possibly do with what i had you know but
i really like the original that's why
but this am i spent seventy thousand in
samples alone
i don't have that type of money that was
putting into an album you know what i'm
saying let's pretend you have an album
with smoking and drinking on it yeah
that one that didn't really happen
budget
smoking and drinking was not a sample
though no no i'm just saying i like that
album yeah whatever that piece is with
you on the cover i like a couple songs
from that
let's pretend janet jackson comes to you
let's pretend joey diaz comes to you
tomorrow
he goes hey man i like the beginning of
smoking and drinking
i want to use it on my next cd and
you're like 50 000.
oh no see i'm saying that that oh that
goes through like my publishing deal
okay so that just shines a publishing
deal like like i don't even know like i
just signed a publishing deal
i've just always like i just renew a
publishing deal not too long ago but
i don't be knowing like you signed a
publishing deal and just one day you
wake up or your song is on tv show
you gotta pay for it yeah i mean you
know you got the little checks and but
he'll be like that you know
i mean you get the first pay-in from the
publishing company their first signing
bonus and then after that they got it
you know they're trying to recoup up
that
so
you just look up you'll see
for that
i mean no hell no
yes that's the difference that's the
difference that's what i'm saying you're
popular in the [ __ ]
yeah you're right everybody let you use
them
because i can't let you use i've always
listened yeah
find me janet jackson
in 94
no no no no 97 she put out an album
called the velvet rope yeah bella wrote
was lit who's give me the songs she was
on her freaking [ __ ] i like that album
that's what she dumped she even had a
masturbating skit on there or some [ __ ]
that album was lit
on the side of the dartmouth i'll tell
you that that was your most hip-hop
album though
what's the songs on that okay give me
one second here that was her most like
that was like
some real it was like some dilla [ __ ] on
there to be honest like really like some
detroit [ __ ] on that album to be honest
i [ __ ] with that album so there's the
six singles is that what you want i
brought that out i don't know the velvet
rope
i can't believe now i bought this album
i remember this
but that was the time like i actually
missed that like i remember the time in
my life like every saturday
i just go to the record store and
everybody that's why i grew up in a
licensed store i i had to buy something
i don't care like the coolest outfit i
guess it was something right time and i
just grabbed the velvet rope one time
like i got gotta grab this that's that
that's single cracking
nothing else you know what i'm saying i
gotta just grab it i might have a girl
over or something more here janet throw
it on but velvet rope was lit all right
so we got uh
twisted elegance velvet rope you
got
got till it's gone
that's the fire one
interlude
uh my need
what else
uh speakerphone they're two interludes
so maybe it's like a skit the one that
don't play nobody but you oh
you
yeah see that's the one
like this song here she samples this
whole [ __ ] jam
all right she paid though but part two
to that it's like it comes out of your
budget like they give you a budget for
album so from janet jackson she gets a
better so who knows she probably three
millions back then i had a three million
dollar budget that includes the videos
too yeah nobody makes videos it cools
videos right here
[Applause]
yeah i remember this [ __ ]
how do you always find live [ __ ]
i'm okay sorry don't worry about it but
that's
she paid them but
like it's i don't
it's dope to be honest to me is art
i like it i kind of like it i love it i
like i like i like it i don't like it i
like it not like in essence where you
taking it like loops is cool where you
taking something and it's just a hope
it's just a
reinterpretation of that piece
and that's cool but i love when you can
take something like that and just chop
it up and deconstruct it to the point
where you couldn't even tell where i
sampled that from
well even opp
yeah that's a loop though that's like so
like that's a little bit that's i like
that look yeah because abc [ __ ] who did
it like that but that's but the thing is
about that like
with me
taking something so popular like that a
loop that if you you got to kill that
[ __ ]
you can't come half ass on no [ __ ]
michael jackson sample
what the [ __ ] like
that is too late
i don't know how to what is you gonna
come with on that like you know like
so to me i never i don't know i can't
rap over something that popular i
wouldn't wrap over a sample that
probably no what's the deal and i don't
want to start any any problems but like
for example
i don't know anything about rap and i
know that it's well known that drake
has used other people's lyrics yeah so
like what what what like was that like
stealing no it's not using people's
lyrics they feel like um he used people
waves
but in some sense just like he's not
really used people waves he put people
on too and whatever what that means is
like
let's just say you made a song lee right
right you made a song and you just some
kid from somewhere and you had on the
internet and
it wasn't really popular like that but
it was popular in your little circle it
was popping in your look you know your
situation and then
now he's jump on and shed some light on
it
and yeah it made the song more popular
and it got the song on the radio you
became a big star it became a hit song
but
that's all it was for you and it just
was another hit under his belt okay so
and now when you try to do it on your
own you can't
okay let's start this from scratch
you're in detroit mm-hmm
you're the king of your [ __ ] little
hip-hop community within a mile
yeah because you had to you had to do
that
at one point in time i had to do that
whatever the [ __ ] sweet tooth
on lancashire that belongs to lisa he
wraps his depth off over there it's
white young jews they jump up and down
i see you
you don't go see them
yeah joey diaz best rapper in the game
plays the kobold arena
or whatever the cobo
he comes up to me and says joy what are
you doing afterward you know me dog i
ain't got no after party
but one of my girls says
she's popping off over at
where dee brown is the thing all right
i walk in d brown is doing his setup on
stage
you know you got a couple songs recorded
you're working at the tire shop to put
your demo together
you know you're like [ __ ] dude in
eight miles yeah i come in i hear you
sing smoking and drinking
what happens now i take it from you
or i sing it better than you and put you
on the song to do two lyrics you get two
dollars and you go [ __ ] that's your
little knapsack that's probably the
second option
so let's say i go in there i like you
the way that song is popping off i give
you a hug we high five
we're black we're beautiful all that
[ __ ] game okay
we're going to the studio a week later
you tell your family drake is flying me
up they pushing a hotel
he sends some [ __ ] chicken there in a
room you know you go to the studio you
lay it down he sings the whole thing he
adds lyrics to your jam
you go home what do you sign now
your life away
is there any percentage your life away
you signed everything away from the
writer
that's the point of it is you want to
make a career out of rap music
that's the that's the goal that's what
people are not realizing there are
people in rap music with careers
like
literally careers like you're not
looking at them like the biggest rapper
in the world you're not thinking about
them but they tour all the time they can
tour it when they want they can make an
album they can get a budget from their
label whenever they want to make an
album you feel them saying then you have
these big guys that
you got to stay on the radio you once
you don't make a hit your label might
drop you like you know 360 deals which
is the worst [ __ ] that ever been
invented in music history that's what's
probably killed rap music and 360 deal
is when you know now you signed to a
major label they taking the money from
your merch
to take the money from your show
and they take the money from your music
back in the day what i known is that the
record label
the music business only take music
you make money from your merch and you
make the money from your shows and
that's the way i feel you know
like you know i i
my principle in it that's probably why i
can't
i would never really sign with major
labels right because now they don't make
money on music yeah they gotta take it
all so they gotta take a piece of
everything your t-shirts yeah they take
your toys and your in the old days i
give you a a budget which is basically
an advance right yeah so once the album
drops because you're really trying to
stash that you know everybody's trying
to stash their advance even though i
this last album i spent more than what i
got
on my [ __ ] you know and i got prayed i
mean i don't talk but i gotta say i
spent 70 000 examples alone and i'm on
an independent company and i don't have
that type of money to be spending on
[ __ ] music so like when you're i got
a [ __ ] big family i'm from detroit
you get what i'm saying like so when you
go on the road now there's three
different t-shirts oh yeah hell yeah we
have a whole [ __ ] booth full of merch
you know but the thing is about that
with merch i feel like you can't burn it
out you have to make it still cool and
exclusive and like when you make it too
much that's when you know i feel like
it's just become like
i don't know it just feel like you
thirsty people can piss at me because i
don't put on enough merch yeah i just
feel like you're thirsty i don't like it
either i don't want a real character
i want you to come over and shake my
hand yeah
yeah i just don't if you want it you'll
get it yeah you'll get it it's online i
don't want to push it i don't want to
buy a t-shirt
over
my wife went to lunch and the person
told me that my wife and so my wife
started giving me luggage with shirts
and i [ __ ] hated it
she did it like four times and one day i
just left the shirts i'm not doing this
no more and then we got the shirts
yeah
boxes boxes and boxes of t-shirts in the
hotel like [ __ ] you want to buy a shirt
go online i'm not carrying that [ __ ] i
love you yeah i love you if you wanna
buy a shirt
but it's not my primary business i wanna
focus on my comedy i don't wanna focus
on shirts and sunglasses and [ __ ]
uh it just makes me not that's not what
i got into it for
you know for one thing like i just
really like like i say i like the
writing aspect of it more than anything
like i
for me like like that's one thing i love
like that's what people don't understand
like with rapping it's so easy to be
honest like
just like comedy or something it's
pretty much set up set up punchline type
[ __ ] you feel me
so
with me i just pretty much just try my
best to just like
make the [ __ ]
most original [ __ ] i can possibly do
because rap music has been around for
[ __ ]
it's it's still relatively new but it's
still it's getting old at this point
where it's still like i don't know
it's weird and it's still always they
say it's a young man's game but it's
like old men still running you know
it's like a weird facade like rap music
is i can't really put my no one will
ever be able to put their finger on it
and that's what make it so cool
i'm going to tell you what else is about
right man because any day it's like the
american dream any day some kid can just
make a video on youtube and become just
the star
of tomorrow there's a lot of good
[ __ ]
and like you know there's a lot of good
rap music and a lot of artistic guys
you're very artistic in your music
i like what you do but there's a lot of
bad rap music oh oh
there's a lot of bad comedy there's a
lot of bad feelings things about rap
music i hate when people say like people
say like it's bad rap music it's always
been bad rap music
which one you want me to move that the
uh hennessy oh my bad
i want this one
but look people say like it's bad rap
music it's always been bad rap music
i don't remember a time in my life where
it wasn't bad rap music
now it
it's always something good there's
always some bad
is it never been all good yeah it's
never been when you go to county jail
and that brother gives you that tape
and he says dog this is the [ __ ] every
year of a good rapper every year you
could tell me about a good rapper i can
tell you about the trash and [ __ ] that
was came out that year too it never was
always with some trash [ __ ] that was
cracking i don't like the new stuff let
me tell you something it's what i'm
saying no it's ray rap music has always
been what it is it is that's what i'm
saying that's what i really feel like to
myself
i'm just more like i love i'm a fan of
rep but it's my environment that control
that
it's from where i'm from it's just my
blood it's just what i was like
gangbanging like people like we were
talking about earlier with games i was
born into rap music
if i was born into [ __ ] rock music
i'd have been playing a guitar singing
in a band now when who was the first rap
that you heard that you said this is it
i'm definitely hello cool j
no [ __ ] radio
no [ __ ]
first i remember i was in kindergarten
like i said
i did that rap in the class so then one
day i remember my uncle
i mean i need my uncle he's my cousin
uncle
you know how it is you know so many baby
daddies and family type [ __ ] but my
cousin uncle
came in he was babysitting me he came
and picked me up from school
and he was like hurry up [ __ ]
i swear it's
ain't got time to be playing with you
man we gotta hurry the [ __ ] up i'm
trying to hear this [ __ ]
and he dragged me the [ __ ] like ran like
in the rain like ran all the way [ __ ]
home
and once we got to the crib we got in
the basement and then he whipped that
[ __ ] he whipped it out and it was
that [ __ ] album with that [ __ ]
radio on it on the cover
pulled that vinyl out and put it on the
plate
and that [ __ ] first two beats dropped
and all i remember just was like oh yes
this is what i'm doing with the rest of
my [ __ ] life
facts like ain't nothing else for me
like this is what it is and who
solidified that what was the second
album ever since then that's what it was
the second album like i say
ever since then i was just it was it was
on like so i probably like bad [ __ ]
before i realized what was good
you get me because i still went through
the phases of a kid liking like [ __ ]
like kid and play
like i was still a kid like an mc hammer
you know i still like that
i didn't know what was good rap music or
bad rap music but the point is was that
i had a young dad
like my dad bought me wu-tang first
album
he just gave it to me i didn't know who
the [ __ ] wu tang was
just brought wu-tang album and just gave
it to me like listen to this [ __ ] but
you know so it was to the point i was on
a level like that with my dad but he
knew how i liked rap music you know
you said earlier like like you like the
writing a lot could you make a living
just like writing lyrics for people
but that's the hard part do i want to
write the songs that make that type of
money that will support that type of
lifestyle you get what i'm saying
because right now you got to think with
rap music like we say is still
like you say it sucks so we got to make
rap music good how can you make rap
music good
you know this point like people making
[ __ ] like you say like the [ __ ] you like
like zeppelin and sabbath
rappers being like progressive and
experimental at this point you know
[ __ ] are still doing them same
drinking you know what i'm saying
and doing rap music or not like that
that is i feel like you know like
it almost said it almost was at that
point where almost like some 70s [ __ ]
but it never really could just break the
mold you know what i'm saying i'm still
in the middle
i never saw avatar i never did either
that's right i'll tell you why i never
saw him
700 million okay so now the movie gets
selected i never tried the time ever
swear to god holy [ __ ] and it pissed me
off because listen
if i gave a three-year-old 700 million
dollars
they could give me back something that's
not bad within a [ __ ] year okay
my mentality is this
i like rap music i don't like it over
produced
okay the same thing with me that's why i
like it minimal that's what i said i
like it minimally produced and i still
want to feel like i'm there i want to
feel like i'm walking to get a nickel
bag facts if that's what's not beating
like i'm going to get a nickel if it
doesn't scare you it's not right
if there's some [ __ ] you can play around
your [ __ ] grandma
this is [ __ ] you can you know what i'm
saying your mind like it's some pc [ __ ]
like no
i like the beastie boys
would i take them into battle with me
not really
i like the beastie boys people get mad
at me you don't play the beast i like
the
but back in the day
with the equipment and [ __ ] that
they were using to make rap music and
with all the [ __ ] that they was doing
like creatively and experimentally like
with compared to what we do today it's
not even coming close
like they used to have like 12 samples
in one record but you go back and listen
to those public enemy records with like
bomb squad and [ __ ] it's like
that [ __ ] is you can't even pay you
wouldn't even be able to [ __ ] clear
that type of [ __ ] you wouldn't be able
to even make those type of records today
they [ __ ] it up not saying they [ __ ]
it up because they made amazing music
doing what they did but you couldn't
even do that type of [ __ ] right now they
used to have like 10 samples on one song
i would love to do [ __ ] like that you
know with me
but it's just it's expensive to make rap
music the way i want to make it
and it's cheap to make rap music
that's popular right now
and that's the best way i can explain it
do you have to balance making songs that
are you think are going to be popular
versus songs that you actually i just
don't i mean i just don't that's not my
world
you know i don't know
that way you don't think about it yeah i
just thought it's not my world i just
look i'm happy with where i'm at like i
say i came in this [ __ ] just thinking if
i could get a [ __ ] if i could just be
fresh and pay my rent and smoke good
i'm happy with that spend the night
and i sure passed yeah and that way
surpassed that i got out of jail [ __ ]
2007 with it like i'm gonna be a rapper
dream you feel what i'm saying and it's
2017 10 years later and like [ __ ] i've
been here like five years already like
it's already you know what i'm saying
like i'm already trying to explore other
options at this point well it's totally
better than that play that tony bennett
[ __ ]
yoho
how much fun did you have in county jail
[ __ ]
i had a lot of fun
only reason why i had fun because i
think i i don't know if you call it luck
but i got lucky lucky
[ __ ] lucky man and i got the best
[ __ ] job in the jail man and i work
no i worked in the kitchen first to be
able to see but it all breaks down the
rap music so when i got look so
breakdown of what you said earlier lee i
was asking me how did you feel when you
first i didn't know that when i first
got caught my case i caught a
distribution and manufacturing case for
weed how do you manufacture weed i don't
know what the case know what it was was
that our posters got a possession with
an intent to distribute
but we had a gun
you know when they raided us we had a
gun so they was like we'll drop the gun
case if you take a distribution with
manufacturing
you know lawyers that's what we
bargained so that's what we took we took
the distribution case over the
manufacturing case because that was
gonna get us to probation
i mean i guess it was a i don't know
i took that but i got probation for that
and you know me i just violated the
probation off rip like not even
i think i no i didn't try for it i just
started smoking weed and started
like i still just i just never acted
like it ever happened
but i still went like
i ran away for like five years before i
even got caught i was flying going to
other states i remember i got caught in
the airport one time me and my homie
trying to go to miami just to like [ __ ]
around with some [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
just like turn up
and i had like
8 000 on me and my homie had like maybe
like he probably like more he had like
probably 20 000 on him just in cash to
chilling but you know you can't have
more than five thousand in the airport
what i thought it was time
yeah change you can't make a change what
are you wearing right now
i don't know
but whatever i had that warrant though
what about the dea grabbed us up just
detroit airport the dea
grab us up just because we had too much
money on this they said
and they took us whatever took us in the
room sorry said we ain't had [ __ ] you
know they never found them but they had
money
but then they ran my name and they had
that warrant
and they asked me they said so we can
just take this money
or we could take you to jail what's your
choice oh my god
he's about to go to
miami it's my birthday
it's my birthday weekend
they shook down homie for his 22. yes oh
that's cold-blooded cold they took it
yeah they got me in mine they got me in
detroit too coming back from
detroit's [ __ ] crazy i was coming
from the improv to go to montreal oh see
that can't it's just canada in general
though every time i go to canada they
[ __ ] shut me down
my plan was to
land in detroit airport go to a hotel in
detroit chill for a few days
and then try to sneak into
canada somebody in detroit said there
could help me go through the bridge
yeah [ __ ] no [ __ ] that [ __ ] way before 9
11.
see before 9 11 i used to sneak into
canada through buffalo
because my friend's dad had a gambling
pass
so they would just wave this
[ __ ] in and then he would drop
me off at the bus station
in that place and i would take a bus to
toronto
i thought i could do that to winter you
know that's where i was gonna go
so i go to [ __ ] detroit i'm at this
hotel
and like the second night i went out in
detroit i took a a cab to greet down
here retail and i started walking around
then i went into a bar and somebody sold
me a grandma
you still found blood
in detroit in greece i went back to look
for cocos
coco house comedy and coco's was closed
so guess what my hotel was four blocks
from cocos i went right to the hood you
know me though
44 hours a night and you get two free
thousands dirty movies
what street is this you remember hell
people getting stabbed
but you don't give a [ __ ]
so again they say it's lawless it's so
funny it was wallace
they kept
they don't give a [ __ ] you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you could
literally like i've literally seen
people get killed like what bro
you still live there with you
take your mama get out this has to be 19
years ago i think about it all the time
lee i think about it all the time
sometimes i think about it like
i might have [ __ ] up
all right so i think i might lose so
listen to this so i'm i'm in i'm waiting
for the camera [ __ ] up i guess
what happened this is 1998. okay 90. oh
no this deal was hot how's it going
i have no idea
and next thing you know the people come
they meet
and they say to me listen man it's going
to be really hard to get i told you i
said god damn yeah i am in detroit
canada
i hug these listen to me dog i hug these
[ __ ]
hug them and say thank you we'll figure
it out
as i'm walking the streets of detroit
it's four o'clock i hear a horn beep
i turn around and this is lesbian dude
named mimi
dude a lesbian
mimi gonzalez and [ __ ]
she was in town to do comedy and she
didn't have a hotel and i said so come
stay with me
because she was living in her van at the
time this is [ __ ] crazy
mimi gonzalez just saw you roaming the
streets
out here yeah i'm just saying yeah
because i was a cuban jewish lesbian of
course and she lived in hollywood so you
saw a random
she saw me i don't know
listen when you're in detroit you don't
look up you look down
act like [ __ ] ain't wrong but [ __ ] what
is that i don't stop for nobody [ __ ]
that is detroit
yelling joey joey yeah
like that's like like that's like you
have to grow up and just know that like
you have to be instilled with certain
like it's like common sense and it's
like street
street common sense you know ideally
those cities the trade is a place where
if you don't have street common sense
you will get don't eat yup
don't don't listen don't take this [ __ ]
out dude they
don't take this dude they will bring him
into the street hit him with a car he
goes down they'll go
and you come over there he'll bang it
yeah
keep walking wherever you were going
keep walking i'm going to cancel my trip
to detroit on the street is a pigeon no
this is just detroit this is every city
is anywhere they run again everywhere
anywhere where there's tourism look the
cops are even coming no tourism in
detroit well they used to be
no never
not to me like no no no not to you i've
been from there like
i mean
i guess just like i say i remember being
a kid and always hearing about coco's
house of comedy on the radio and i was
like yeah and before that it was uh
something else there was two of them but
the main one was uh
all things so detroit is always like any
place i feel like with that much
depression always wants some [ __ ]
light of sunshine so it always was a
comedy scene tons of comments tons from
royal oak yeah to uh traverse city one
of my homies like he was like a comic
from detroit like he moved out here now
he's starting to do good night yeah
that was when i first got here there was
four brothers from detroit that were
tearing it up up here they got a deal
from cosby's company
they got a deal from puffy's company
they called themselves something but
then one of them got into a car accident
thomas ward is still around
they were funny [ __ ] in fact
they lived up here
they lived down the corner 20 years ago
i used to hang
any place that i feel like that
is that the present to be at you always
be able to create some type of way to
make
of like i say a rare sunshine you know
what i'm saying like even with me with
rap music that was my getaway that was
the way i escaped being where i was at
me going in my basement
and just writing a song and recording it
like i said i sing it to myself and i
thought it was dope it
like
and then i make it and then other people
was like oh [ __ ] it's tight and you know
before i know like even with me with the
internet [ __ ] that [ __ ] happened when i
went to jail and i didn't know about
putting my music on the internet and
nothing like that like to me i just
thought internet was [ __ ] going on
chat rooms and
jerking off on porn to some weird [ __ ]
and stuff i don't know you know i didn't
know what the internet really was like
that you know
but when i was in jail my brother
started putting my songs on like random
websites and [ __ ] and then when i got
out of jail i kind of had like i i
missed that whole myspace era
when i got out of jails like twitter was
just starting
where i caught on the twitter early
you know
as a luck you know
and then i just started being on twitter
and just
started just promoting myself on twitter
like early like maybe it's like 2 000
whenever twitter started i feel like it
was really like when it first started
type [ __ ] cause i remembered it it was
on the sidekick
i had the sidekick phone that's what i
was doing i was never calling off the
other side yeah i was saying like when
you really had to type a whole person
name you had to hit the you know saying
it wasn't even dm sometimes you had to
really say what you wanted to say on the
[ __ ]
i was on twitter like really like
cracking when it wasn't even dms like
and that's what i feel like my music
took a turn that's when [ __ ] changed
because before then it was like me just
being in detroit like going to open mics
where i wasn't really accepted for the
type of [ __ ] that i wanted to do with my
music and then
it was like when i went up to new york
or if i went to la because i was coming
out here too you know what i'm saying
trying to do music and stuff i never
would fit into what was poppa or what
was considered to be
i don't know
like to be i don't know i was just doing
what i liked
you know and it never would like i click
with people in some type of way
but once like i guess like
2011
like when triple x came out it just it
clicked you know it just was a time when
it clicked because i was knocking on
that door forever
you know
i was 30 years old
my [ __ ] when people started
acknowledging me as a rapper like it's
nothing worse to me
like i feel like then telling a person
you're a rapper
like that's like the worst [ __ ] ever to
tell a person you're a rapper because
you don't never supposed to have to tell
a person you're a [ __ ] rapper
you feel everybody posted nothing
if you have to tell a person you're a
rapper then guess what you're not a
[ __ ] rapper
and it's just embarrassing
to even have to go through that you know
now you said that your brother was
putting the tapes on for you online yeah
when i was younger where were you taping
this
no i was just random no i was going to
new york what happened was okay
i had a group
called reservoir dogs which is my cousin
another homie chips
and dope head we had it we had a group
called reservoir dogs we made album we
put it out
and it was kind of it was it was decent
but it wasn't you know it wasn't nothing
that was going to change your life you
feel me
so but what we did we had money involved
in us
a whole nother world of the [ __ ] we had
[ __ ] involved with us that was
like doing bank scam [ __ ] like scamming
the checks and [ __ ] so like them
trying to make this was the days of like
like master p and like cash money you
know that [ __ ] came out so anybody with
money thought they could just start a
record label and one day they could
become a [ __ ] millionaire
so i had a homie that was like doing
bank scam [ __ ]
like the type of [ __ ] where you just
that type of [ __ ] [ __ ] doing
that like you got a bank account they
just take a random check and deposit 10
000 in your account
it clear they get you 2 000 and take
this you know what i'm saying take the
eight and then whoever find it they
split they give them two thousand and
they taking the six and he used to have
like three people a day like he was just
making like
so he just invested in the record label
one day with me rapping because i was
just broke as [ __ ] smoking weed in my
[ __ ] basement recording songs on the
[ __ ] four track
and then he just made it um he made
album with me like put the money into it
where i can get in the studio paper
producer
and we made album as a group but
it just and then we paid for songs to
get on the radio like literally pay for
djs to play our songs on the radio and
[ __ ] like that and like how much would
it cost a lot of [ __ ] money like like
we got a [ __ ] fire
we gotta make a fire for the radio
station i swear to god like so but we
paid this [ __ ] like
like 5 000 to play a song on radio but
the [ __ ] played it like to the point
where it got kind of like popular so he
was like doing like local shows and it
was like popular but
and so what happened was he tried to
take the music you know he like the
numerator coming to do so he went to
like def jam like record labels with the
music and [ __ ]
and anr at rockefeller really liked the
[ __ ] like he really wanted to [ __ ] with
it like we're trying to get it cracking
but once they did the deal i mean did
the meeting for it when they went into
the [ __ ] i don't know i wasn't there
yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] was
saying to me
when they came back it was like this
[ __ ] didn't happen it was a like i just
was hurt like all i knew was
[ __ ] went to new york
and [ __ ] met with [ __ ]
and
they said they were trying to do a deal
and then the next thing i know the deal
didn't happen but what ended up coming
out was that the [ __ ] that went
in there that put the money into it when
you know talking crazy talking you know
just extra trying to get you know just
talking you know
so that didn't happen but some type of
way i still got the anr connect from one
of my friends
that was there with one of the guys
and i just contacted him and told him
who i was like i'm danny brown from the
group reservoir dogs i had this you know
he's like oh yeah i remember the show
[ __ ] with that [ __ ]
you could come out here you know i
checked and i was making my own solo
[ __ ] at the time already
so i had a mixtape already that i made
and i just came up there with that
mixtape
and then he took me to a studio
in queens
and i just started recording at that
studio and i made like three mixtapes
there like i'm talking about years every
time about years of work now like i
would go to like [ __ ] new york like
have like i was broke as [ __ ] like i was
living sleeping on couches i'm down at
homeless at this point i'm bouncing from
like my arms to grandmas to like aunts
sleeping wherever i could sleep smoking
whoever weed i could smoke you know
bumming cigarettes like that type of
[ __ ]
saying i'm gonna be a rapper
you know just trying to figure it out
thank god i went to jail to be honest
because i think going to jail made me a
rapper because before the end this this
is before jail this is when i had the
warrants and i couldn't you know already
what did i already violate the probation
so now i'm just trying to be a rapper
but i know
any given moment
police can [ __ ] type my name and it's
a rap you feel what i'm saying and i'm
flying i'm that's why i was catching the
greyhound in new york so i go to great i
go to [ __ ] new york with [ __ ] 300
to sleep on the [ __ ] studio floor
and he would because he gave me that and
alright rockefeller didn't even have
that much pull
to even get me signed nowhere i even do
anything but he was just i was able to
come out there and he would
and you know show me love i'd be able to
sleep at his crib and [ __ ] you know
go to the studio record music i would
just try to record as much music i can
make
and like i say eventually i had enough
songs that when i went to jail my
brother just made mixtapes out of them
i didn't wasn't thinking about doing
none of that type of [ __ ] i was thinking
about getting a [ __ ] record deal
because that's what i knew to be a
rapper
so when i came back home out of jail i
kind of had like a name a little bit
like my mind space like had like fans
like he had people writing me in jail
and [ __ ]
brown and all this [ __ ] and i'm like oh
[ __ ] you know like maybe it is something
you know
and then once i got out of jail i was
like oh [ __ ]
but i went right back to hustling though
when i got out of jail though i still
had the [ __ ]
because i was still kind of like
homeless though that's the worst part
like you want to get out of jail like i
felt like that was the worst thing
to me to be honest like you say like how
much fun you had in jail and i was like
i had a lot of [ __ ] fun
but i remember the first day being out
of jail and being like what the [ __ ] now
you know what i'm saying you missed that
salami family yeah i mean i just knew in
jail i mean well only sandwich i guess
freaking cheese i wanted to be no i
but i'm just saying i remember being
like i mean i guess you
institutionalized at that point
or i don't know but i remember coming
back and being like what the [ __ ] i'm
gonna do you know i didn't have a plan
so i had to go back to hustling
i remember i hooked back up with my
homies and now they were selling weed
but they was getting the pounds from
arizona
and the only job i could get then was
like just lowering the trucks up with
the pounds that we cuz flying in mexico
i mean not mexico but flying to arizona
and these [ __ ] mexico [ __ ]
don't even speak english
now that they stealing money like
like the most sketchy should i ever been
a part of and i just remember like
i mean we were still like he would i
would have to like fly out to like
arizona like load trucks up you know
load the trucks up that's what i get
paid for put the weed on the trucks
that's what i was gonna pay for
but like three thousand pounds
[ __ ] like that
i would break like 2500 to run
so it was like maybe doing like maybe
one in a month
you know and you're good it keeps your
dream a lot
but i was trying to be a rapper at that
time yeah that's what you're doing
you're financing your dream and but
every time i was doing it i feel like
[ __ ] i'm going to jail i'm going to go
back to jail like i was really scared
like before like you leave like greg
said back in the day and i was selling
cracking apartments and [ __ ] i wasn't
scared
i wasn't worried about nothing
but once i got to that
like that [ __ ] like putting 3 000 pounds
of [ __ ] trailer tractor
and [ __ ] going to miami with [ __ ]
50 000 drink for ice on that ain't yours
because they just want you to look good
because they with you and you and you
know what i'm saying like i'm like i'm
going back to jail this is what
i told myself in jail i'm not gonna do
and then once i got back out i was right
back in it you know so i was trying to
be a rapper
and what we hated as drug dealers was
rappers
what do you hate more than anything like
when we went to like the strip clubs or
like like [ __ ] like had money like
like real money like we go to atlanta we
go to [ __ ] like you got real money
like and you got these rappers that
don't even got money like you got
but the [ __ ] is all on the rappers
all the strippers all unwrapping them
if the rappers got a hit yeah i mean
period the rapper's gotta it was like
that but even with me like that wasn't
the drive of it but i remember like all
my drug dealing that that life of being
a drug dealer like being around the drug
dealing friends they hated rappers more
than anything
so me just popping up saying i wanted to
be a rapper
was like
no one [ __ ] with me after that like
they just cut me off like literally like
cut me off like stop [ __ ] with me
like you rap like i don't [ __ ] with and
i was rapping my whole life before i
even met them they just didn't know it
and i bump into one rapper
every week lee hold this i gotta go to
the bathroom but i bump into
not
danny brown rap
you know what i'm saying but somewhere
along the line if i go to the audition i
go to a meeting
there's always one dude in there with
some [ __ ] outfit on
looking like a rugby clown yeah he's a
rapper
what's up danny
time is how much time we gonna live
i don't know we got a few minutes left
um
[ __ ]
i wasn't gonna ask
what would you say because i i i told a
little people were super excited you
were coming on
and someone had said like oh it's so
funny that people are like know that i
[ __ ] with this [ __ ] so i know like yeah
how did that how did that happen like
how did like did you because i oh i
watched hot ones and i saw it there
no but the first time i saw it was on
twitter yeah of course this is how [ __ ]
because you know i like video games
lately you know i'm a gamer like i play
video games a lot you like video games
i i do but i'm not good at them so i
quit eating yeah i didn't it's kind of
like that with me yeah that's probably
why like i was you know but whatever but
yeah i don't i don't finish a lot of
games this time either but i like that
but i bought them all i tried them out
and see them but i don't finish a lot of
them
but well how it literally how having was
with video games just being on the road
buying video games and i bought ufc ah
that's a hard game too so i started
playing ufc and from me started playing
ufc
i started liking joe rogan
just from the video game version
i'm sorry this is years ago though this
is years in the process of just making
okay so
then i started watching joe rogan
until one day i see this guy
so now i become a fan of this guy this
is all come from you know what i'm
saying from video this is where it came
from
that's crap wait what what ufc too i
wasn't even a fan of ufc when i bought
the video game it just was a cool game
yeah i just was only i was on tour i was
on the road i just bought everybody i
was just you know you're on the bus you
play video games you buy dvds you watch
movies you know so i would just one day
on the road was like [ __ ] it i'm gonna
buy oh [ __ ] ufc a fighting game i've
never been on the road ufc i didn't even
know of ufc fighter name at the time
now i'm so engulfed in [ __ ] ufc is
like runs my [ __ ] world like
my [ __ ] like you know what i'm saying
like
and
like i can't even explain it like it
changed my life in some sense
and like being like even learning about
like
because even the point of like like i
say like it went from [ __ ] just me
buying that video game on the road
and then hearing joe rogan on the
[ __ ] video game being like oh joe
rogan is dope and just liking joe rogan
to start watching real ufc fights for me
liking the video game just to want to
learn about the fighters that i was
fighting with on the [ __ ] game so now
i'm learning now i'm watching real ufc
so now i learned about joe rogan i like
joe rogan so now i watch joe rogan
podcast now i [ __ ] learned about you
you know what i'm saying now it just
trickles down effect and so now i just
watch now part of church
you feel upset
and we love it now i'm here smoking dope
on the
church you know what i'm saying and it
started from a wfc video game on twitter
do you feel what i'm saying but that's
the way life happened see what i'm
saying if you don't if you don't look at
the little signs and [ __ ] and just
realize it and just respect it what it
was what i'm saying when i was washing
my hands i was thinking i wanted to ask
you something
because this is how i felt you know
i [ __ ] around for years
got locked up did my time
and when i walked out of that prison i
felt like all my sins were absorbed you
know i'm saying yeah be true though like
that's how i felt that's what i felt
that's why i never went back so i feel
like that's that's the most like to me
the most like i'm i'd rather die than go
back to jail bro
like the most that's the most scariest
[ __ ] to me
is to go back to jail it wasn't that it
was scary i just don't i just don't ever
want to go through that i didn't belong
in there i don't want to go through that
ever you belong
i think
like with me
i had the i had the best job which is
the worst job
and the best job in wayne county jail is
[ __ ] registry so i work registry and
that's when you get registered in so the
[ __ ] that work registry is the
[ __ ] that really control the
whole county because when you come in
guess what you got your cigarettes on
you you may got a bag of weed in your
ass you may got whatever
that all happens in registry once you
get changed out of your real clothes and
get put in your greens and go to your
flow whatev
i'm the only [ __ ] down there that works
that [ __ ] [ __ ] like i'm gonna
[ __ ] get your cheese sandwich when
you're working this [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying i'm the only [ __ ] male
inmate that even interacts with female
inmates
i had so many [ __ ] female [ __ ]
writing to me i ain't even had people
out the outside right
i would just take the [ __ ] court
slips
and find a [ __ ] and then see her and
know her name and then just take the
[ __ ] her number mma number just to
write the [ __ ] off rip i'm the [ __ ]
work at registry i see you going to
court
how have you given me your sandwiches
i hope your case going
no way
and before we know it now we jerking off
to each other letters but what the rest
of our bit you feel what i'm saying do
you ever hear them i had mo [ __ ] in
jail in that jail right me i swear no
one was writing me on the outside they
were like it was over for that eight
months i didn't even want to let her
from any i didn't even tell anyone to
visit
i had to crack it once i got the
registry and it happened for me being a
[ __ ] rapper like rapping because at
first you know you get the [ __ ]
kitchen job and i was working [ __ ]
like the [ __ ] dishes
and that [ __ ] they called that [ __ ]
water world i was in water world working
that [ __ ] [ __ ] getting splashed
up
washing dishes and [ __ ] [ __ ] up and
then it was these two [ __ ] on
my pod they ran my [ __ ] too it was a big
ass [ __ ] this [ __ ] like [ __ ] six
[ __ ] i don't know he looked like a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] travis brown or something you
know what i'm saying he that's the [ __ ]
who ran my flow you know what i'm saying
he wanted to be a rapper but he was
trash i swear everybody like he was just
so trashy listen to this you don't want
to
i mean whatever no he's not but he
probably in jail right now but he was so
trashed and they used to rap every night
like just all night like like i would
like when they lock us down
they will be supposed to go to sleep
you could hear these [ __ ] sails away
just rapping
and they say it's mr like the whack is
like it's just so tragic all night all
night i told bro and i'm not even and
i'm not even i didn't even tell [ __ ] i
could rap i ain't told about that no no
no no but they getting on my nerves so
much like it's killing me like it's
irking me like it's making my skin crawl
every night i can't even sleep right
hearing these [ __ ] try to rap
every night
so one day i just get [ __ ] pissed off
and just go in the [ __ ] room
and just unloads a clip and just give
them like
two verses just give them bars like
and show them really how to do it like
just rap for them and just and they were
so [ __ ] up but they felt deceived too
that they wouldn't around me for months
and they've been rapping in front of me
and doing all this and then i just all
of a sudden just come out the blue and
do this in front of them so but they
respected me so much and they knew my
case and they knew oh you know because i
wouldn't know they don't know i wasn't
trying to be a rapper
so once they saw that like i said he ran
our flow the [ __ ] was like six foot
eight like diesel as [ __ ] he told you to
turn the tv off [ __ ] turn the
tv up
you feel what i'm saying he ran our
floor and he was the one that worked
registry so once he left registry he
gave me his job because he felt that
i was going to become a rapper one day
and maybe i would help him i don't know
something but i was so good at rap to
him that he always would invite me to
his [ __ ] cell and be like help me rap
help me write some bars or figure out
some [ __ ] show me how to do this you
know
just
and when he left he gave me his job
so i had registered
your boys going through changes nobody's
like well like what if he
going to try this see look i feel like
i feel like i'm good like i ate the
straw i'm straight
i just another one i feel like i really
accepted it i thought i was really
scared of it i accepted it you want
whatever you wanted to with a clear mind
yeah see i can't i respected it i went
into it see if you don't go into [ __ ]
with respect that's when you get [ __ ]
up there you go you know what i'm saying
you see
six stars soon as i come in here [ __ ]
with y'all [ __ ] come on man anybody do
me like that my niece called me tonight
but what's that one bad is danny brown
really gonna be on the show yeah
i had another niece call me and she's
like listen i gotta talk to you about
something we started talking
about one of the dates i have
excuse me
and she goes can i ask you a question i
go why she goes are you trying to kill
me
thank you i'm like no
he's a trainer right now she's telling
me she goes the most [ __ ] and like
this is denise i can't really understand
i can't see this is the niece that i
grew up
with her uncle
and her mother so she knows
all the [ __ ] stories
when she was a baby they used to hide
the coke
under her crib oh
lit so she'd be in there
she'd be in the crib and this is her her
mattress
it would be in here right so everybody
knew that if you picked up the mattress
you'd wake her up [ __ ] that
you don't know how many times i went in
there five in the morning and creeped up
that mattress just a little oh [ __ ] and
got my little cuban fingers in that
[ __ ] took that baggy out
you know me dog i don't give a [ __ ]
but she goes it's weird how are your
tolerance
she goes i see you eating i see you
smoking i see you eating those stars
and it's because i go into it like
it's a situation i remember when if i
would eat five stars i'd be high for
[ __ ] 12 hours
couldn't stop talking couldn't stop
eating paranoid now
i look at it just as a day in the office
oh my god so how i go into it is how i
walk out of it sure
that's not how it works
that's not how it works
i mean you know more than us
wrong with it
the week of sugar cubes
the the edibles sugar cubes yeah sugar
cube week you still got sugar cubes wait
look at a whole box
so like paper acid too we gotta lose oh
after the after the week of sugar cube
like the animals just aren't as hard
anymore and these lights right here oh
my god oh yeah yeah
i think
you're doing that
but the tolerance thing one time i did
ask it and roll my segway for like two
hours
and you
[Music]
the wind felt so good i thought i was an
angel flying with wings on my back for a
moment
oh my god i just know one of my
neighbors saw me like what the [ __ ] is
danny brown doing
he keeps riding around the corner
already holding his herbs on like he on
the end of the titanic [ __ ]
that's why i can't be good like
hallucinogenic drugs
[ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
i just do goofy [ __ ] better embarrass
myself
listen i went in that bathroom just now
as soon as i turned on the light i got a
flashback that night i did the acid
that [ __ ] me up oh what you did when
you cut that light off
me and him got high now monday night i
was straight
i got a little high in here on the acid
i went home went to bed the second night
with ralphie may
there was a point in here i couldn't
[ __ ] talk towards the end
and i got up to go to the bathroom and
my face was pale
the light in there was green
i went into the pea i forgot what i went
in there for
i washed my hands then i peed it was
[ __ ] up
i came at him like i'm [ __ ] but that's
what i'm saying you are so doing you
know what within 10 or 15 minutes of
acknowledging that
i smoked a little wreath i went home and
made a [ __ ] salami sandwich ooh i got
a corned beef from graham branson right
now wait nobody i'm within 10 minutes i
knew i was a doctor for [ __ ] the
mental aspect i called you grabbing to
take us he was up all [ __ ] night he
wanted to walk around
if lee would have gone home and made a
tuna fish sandwich just sat down and
watched tv
but then
i can't watch tv on acid well yes you
can
uh
you know what the craziest thing ever
happened to me danny brown
i'm writing about it right now like this
is what i'm writing about like this
like right after my mother died
like they buried her on a monday but my
mother's best friend said listen
i'm going to stay at the house
so you could hear it
when you decide what you want to do you
let me know
and you could
i'll leave and i go listen i think i'm
gonna move with the benders
thanksgiving day but why don't you stay
for two weeks
and help me with the transition
so for the first week i was cool you
know we're all cool for the first week
we come home we were supposed to come
home but the second week
i started eating that acid again
and she's living in my mom's bedroom and
i'm living in my bedroom and i got my tv
with the cable and i did ask them one
night i came home and the blob was on
when that thing was coming under the
door and [ __ ]
i started looking under the door and
looking under the door but there's one
scene in that movie why would you watch
that oh my god like that [ __ ] [ __ ] me
up like normally channels like turn the
tv off and do what sit there in the dark
gonna hit the ass it's better than the
blob no it's not no it's not
you rather take the blob it's steve
mcqueen there was a little bit of comedy
i giggled a little bit then i started
getting paranoid
it didn't help that i had the lights off
i had to turn the [ __ ] lights on once
you turn the lights on yeah everything's
all right everything's that's what made
me realize i still got some acid in my
house that i lost because i was just so
geeked about it when i was half the acid
that i was having such a good time like
i gotta hide this [ __ ]
and i don't even know right
i look for it all the time but i don't
even know where the [ __ ] acid is that
i feel ashamed that i did it it's in the
house i've got some
i don't know where
like the first night i did it i felt
okay but the second night i started
thinking about like i'm a 54 year old
dad that's the thing and i'm doing acid
what the [ __ ] is wrong with me i should
be ashamed of myself
i should be shot [ __ ] hung and thrown
into the prison for doing a hit [ __ ]
what type of dad am i
so now i'm on the fence about it
when i see lee slipping we'll do some
more sugar cubes
just to make them and just you know
there's no guidelines for that it's not
like i could look at here too that's
really strict and that's why we look up
like me like being like 36 and looking
at like i want to be like you when i'm
feeling 54 yeah alive and kicking and
having fun doing ash
you know what i'm saying like i i aspire
to be like you
you know i'm saying more so than to be
some like [ __ ] just bored and just
[ __ ] with life and just stuck in some
[ __ ] that i don't want to be involved in
like you lived your life the way you
wanted to live and now you you know what
i'm saying you're still doing that in
some sense and there's some people that
stuck in [ __ ] because they just
like jobs they don't even want to work
like we're saying that like to me the
american dream is to [ __ ] be able to
make money off of doing something you
love
we have people that's [ __ ]
working jobs making a lot of money and
probably don't even care about it i
don't even hate doing a [ __ ] job you
got people married to [ __ ]
people in relationships they don't
[ __ ] want to be in they don't want to
be around that [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying and they stuck in that [ __ ] like
but i feel like you as you know what i'm
saying like that's what i found when i
first heard you i'm like
this is how i'm [ __ ] growing to be
you know what i'm saying like i'm doing
the [ __ ] i want to do with my art you
know what i'm saying like you with your
comedy and me with my rap i feel like
it's the same kind of way like same man
i didn't sacrifice it but and maybe me
like being so [ __ ] up all the time
i'll talk about all the time like that
might be the reason that i didn't
i mean i'm not [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
biggest rapper in the world or whatever
the [ __ ] like you know what i'm saying
you'll go out you didn't want to be but
you wanted to be you could be but you
didn't want to be i still just want to
do something with your life like i did
kind of look at it like selling drugs
stuff
like long as i could be able to make
money off it and i could not like
detract still dangerous i want never to
be able to still even live there and
pray
do what i do
if i didn't keep it as low-key as i keep
it like it's rappers it's local rappers
that's probably getting more trouble
or more like acknowledgement did not get
and i'm [ __ ] i'm saying
but i i like it like that like you said
so i i wanted it like that kind of to be
honest but
i still like i i want i i got what i
want out of it i feel like and it's
i don't know like with far as rap music
it's like i don't know if i like
so much it's only some more i could go
with it
you feel me before i could feel like
like the next level for me is the only
thing i feel like
it's like running a record label like me
just now like going into like
finding those kids that was like me from
detroit that probably
a major label wouldn't like them being
experimental just because
you know like rap music like you say
it's bad rap music is not it doesn't
have a good name
i don't care like i'm a person that's in
it you feel what i'm saying like when
you add the trenches of it when you're
in the trenches or some [ __ ] you can
really talk about it you feel what i'm
saying like no no no
we're talking about like if you don't
have a good name and that guy in the
prison it doesn't have a good name you
feel what i'm saying i love rap music
but there's a lot of not respected it's
not like respect i know who's faking the
funk
you can hear it
there's something about it that you know
when they're faking the funk oh no i was
gonna ask about that i have no idea how
many of these rappers who were saying
like like they would like they're doing
what you just did like sell drugs or
whatever like are they actually doing it
most of them are probably not i mean
it's just like anything else it's all
entertainment anything for entertainment
purposes so anybody that even if i did
sell some drugs i probably would exactly
exaggerate it more just to make it more
absolutely
[ __ ] a dime bag until he sold
keys
you know what i'm
i
saying
three dudes working with me let me give
some shout outs thanks
maverick matthews i love you edsky
ugaldi
stay black my man leon over there in
germany
amy thank you for the birthday wishes
tiger armstrong d alexander
tripp berg burgie
bergy my main armenian over there always
we talked yesterday gymster
daniel riley
and nick nightingale you know
nightingale
you know i love you [ __ ]
don't forget i'll be over at the
minneapolis
house of comedy thursday night [ __ ]
friday and saturday
don't [ __ ] around bring the reefer
bring the pills that kill prince
whatever you got
a wheelchair roller skates
i don't give a [ __ ] jack
i love prince man i love prince too
purple rain was like right i remember
like that's what i'm saying like that's
feel like that's like my childhood i
remember coming home from school like my
mom was like watching purple rain my
whole house like smell like weed but
like you said it was still different
[ __ ] involved like
when i was coming home i was coming home
to a [ __ ] clean house though
sparkling [ __ ] and span in a [ __ ]
cooked meal you smell it too
over the weed like nowadays like [ __ ]
kids like ain't my [ __ ] peter
mcdonald meal do [ __ ] like
it's not even like
i don't know like you said like it was a
different type of parenting even though
my mom was young i still got that old
school parent
because it was that i don't know it was
that generation or that because maybe my
grandma's raised me more so than my
mom's when i think about it now you know
because she was so young she couldn't
really take care of me because i really
went to my filipino grandma
because you know me i was the first i
was the oldest child how was your
filipino grandma
would you like a filipino ground
crazy little [ __ ] she loved you
i mean it was it was just
she sport me a little it was sport but
it was like spoiled crazy so i had to
deal with being spoiled to deal with
crazy so like i could get
those jordans and i could get all that
[ __ ] that i wanted that my mom probably
couldn't afford my grandma could get for
me but if she came home and like
the house wasn't clean
or like little like where is she like
that she would like freak the [ __ ] out
like just like be like trip on me like
it was like weird like i couldn't do
[ __ ] i couldn't bring girls over
couldn't like it was just like extra
strict like extra extra straight my
filipino grandma was like kathleen but
but give me
pentecostal
it was just extra i went to like
i went to [ __ ] church every sunday
church is like when i really realized i
was like really wasn't like a good kid
like i was like fingering [ __ ]
in church yeah
fighting [ __ ] like i was like
that's what i really like did all my cuz
i was like
i used to go to church with her every
sunday like i lived with her like my
brother like my mom's you know excited
like if i live my grandma and [ __ ]
because i wanted to be the only child i
guess though because i was the first one
i don't know i guess that's how it is
when you're like the oldest one i don't
know like kind of like jealous i don't
know
but so me going with my grandma i was
like me being on each other i had my own
bedroom i didn't have to share [ __ ]
didn't have to do nothing so i wanted to
leave my grandma i want to do that but
she was like way more strict than my
black parents like the black [ __ ] so
once i got older i was like [ __ ]
filipino [ __ ]
what does filipino music like i don't
know i mean it's a sign never been in
the philippines the only thing i know is
my grandma i don't know well yeah she
did one of the filipinos i met
was at the church going to church with
my grandma you know other than that it's
not like a real big filipino community
in like michigan i don't think but i
don't know but that's the only filipinos
i met was like going to church before is
that like
but the lifestyle like she still lives
like she [ __ ] in manila
she don't know [ __ ] she met some
[ __ ] that was came from detroit
like i never met my [ __ ] granddad i
don't know what
like i feel like i got his blood all the
way like i don't even know who he was
but i probably feel like that's who i am
probably you know what i'm saying like
they say he was tall as [ __ ]
he just was like a sad but the thing was
he made he went he was in the peace
corps
you know what i'm saying during the
vietnam [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] my
grandma was a school teacher in manila
he met her
brought her back to detroit but then
when he brought her back to detroit he
ended up being a savage
beating the [ __ ] out of her
sins like just
wilding
he died of alcohol poisoning but i don't
really believe he died
poisoned with a palatino crap
kills them
they buried that [ __ ]
35 or whatever you know
i don't really like you know i don't
know people who died alcohol poison i
don't even know [ __ ] that
overdose up coke right now you know what
i'm saying like
you can't even overdose up cook right
now that [ __ ] is like
so bad right now i don't even know like
who even would want to do cup right now
like but let me actually just don't tour
a lot
i just came off a [ __ ] four month
tour
um
where did you go
i went everywhere the united states and
europe
no [ __ ] who offers on the bill me and
another artist signed to my label the
loopers
so just me and him and when do you go
back again i'm not trying to cry
no time soon i guess whenever
something else work out
it happened but first but i guess that's
the most like i don't like you say it i
don't i don't make money off music i
make money off shows you know so
about 10 i mean i'm playing festivals
all i play festivals you know let's say
maybe 10 15 years ago
i'm just giving you numbers
i lived down in hollywood and the kid
upstairs
unbeknownst to [ __ ] me who i saw
every day
and talk to her and he'd walk up down
down with a [ __ ] guitar box
you know i thought he was a student up
the corner everybody got a [ __ ]
guitar right mm-hmm well one day we're
talking in the back there's like a
fourth of july barbecue
and somebody's going strong when are you
going back on the road with limp bizkit
he was in a base of that biscuit he's
going
i go back out
was it west no no no no
this was the opening ban for the biscuit
so
you know after the barbecue i saw him a
few times and one day we were outside
and i had someone smoke a joint
and we started talking like can i ask
you some personal questions so you're on
tour with limb biscuit
because yeah this is limp biscuits
biggest tour
we do
six cities and then
somebody else does six cities then
somebody else does six then we go back
i go how many cities how many cities are
they doing all together
i don't i'm just throwing them brazilian
at the time he goes they're doing
43 cities and i go how many shows are
you guys on
and he goes we're on like 32 of them so
i go
can i ask you a question
why we see you waiting for the [ __ ]
bus it's not right and he goes what are
you talking about
i go
dog i get fifteen dollars a show and i
got a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] caught it's
got no insurance
and the brakes hardly worked at least
nobody giving it a new york try and he
was telling me his deal yeah and it was
they gave it out the album came in top
ten
like number six they did well
but not for
the 70s standards it did well for 1998
and lit biscuit it was on limp biscuits
label or somebody's label and lip
biscuit took them out i just toured with
them
they played for they paid for per diem
hotel
travel that's it and
because you pay i mean
that's what a lot of people don't even
understand that part of the world too i
was like what even be like most of these
like even some of these festivals you
can't even play these festivals if you
don't have the money to pay for them
you got to pay for your own flight in
your own room let's just say of like a
big basketball like a coach like some
certain [ __ ] if you're not that artist
that they want like you know if they
booked you to make you to the point
where they're like you should be
happy that you're on this festival type
of [ __ ] it's like
you paying for your own room or you're
on flight you know what i'm saying so if
you ain't got that money to do that [ __ ]
then you can't even do that
you feel me so you got to turn that
festival down
thank god i always had the money to be
able to do that and i think that's what
made me cuz i think
i took all the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that i did
in drug dealing i didn't do it with rap
music so i always had the money to be
able to play those festivals and cover
those grounds so anytime a big festival
came to me and it was probably something
that i probably like a lot of [ __ ] i
probably did i probably weren't even on
that level to probably play yet but i
was able to afford it to do it
and i was had that name to where i could
bring that draw
so
like now it's like i'm too big i'm too
it's like i'm in a space where it's like
i'm too big for them too over it
like you can't really
it's like how i was when i started it i
don't know if i respect it
enough like i don't i can't explain like
i'm humble and uh and i'm and i'm
[ __ ]
and i appreciate everything that i got
from it but it's not like
it's not
it doesn't like i don't know
but it doesn't drive me like i don't
want to wake up in the morning and write
a rap song well you're pretty good at it
so unless you're gonna become a weather
man
you better get back to just in the words
of paul morning when you want to be
creative you're going to get entertained
yo oh no and that's what i do and i know
that none of that and that's what i try
to do a lot no i'm never was i would rap
for the rest of my life but i'm saying
my whole point is your number one
ambition
and that's what i'm look now let's draw
back to that now i told you in the
beginning my favorite rapper was naz
right yeah my last like when i got out
of my last deal
and i was just trying to assign me to
his label
and mass appeal
and you know we clicked you know we
talked so you like meeting your idol
like you know you know they say you
never should meet you i hate those type
[ __ ] like
i'm meeting the [ __ ] person that
makes me like even want to do the [ __ ]
that i want to do
and when i talk to him he told me that i
was just more than a rapper
that's what his breakdown was like you
were way more than a [ __ ] rapper
and i just thought about that [ __ ] all
the time like what does he [ __ ] mean
by that all right
what do we mean but i'm more than a
rapper so always ever since then i tried
to do [ __ ] that was outsider like to try
to do more than rap so
like doing voiceover work or
just trying to even do like i'm [ __ ]
auditioning for movies and [ __ ] which
[ __ ] sucks
because i don't ever get it
like going on auditions is not something
that like i'm not that's not a part of
my world like
is it frustrating do you wish you were
like now like i'm i'm i'm close i'm
always close to getting the road like
i'm close i i could probably say i got
it but i only want to mention it but
it's fun i'm close yeah
all that stuff is fun
uh and and
you know jim brown played football any
[ __ ]
shot movies you know and
and now you know you put american
gangster on how many [ __ ] rappers are
in that movie t.i
common you know
these are the soundtracks even like you
even with comedy though like i even feel
like even some time with that like now
like even look at comedy with netflix
there's so many [ __ ] comedy specials
on there unbelievable
and i don't like you can't even watch
them all
right too much content and anyway i mean
i mean
most of them aren't even that good like
one month ever every morning i found on
youtube that's better like some random
like
it's almost like rap is like
the way comedy like comedy is cracking
right now but it's almost like
underground [ __ ] the way rat was like i
find myself listening to more podcasts
and i do music now
and i find it [ __ ] up because i make
music and i don't even know what's
cracking right now i'm doing music
because i listen to podcasts i'm
listening to the [ __ ] church
i'm not looking at the blog looking at
what the [ __ ] newest
hottest mixtape is now
i'm listening to [ __ ] podcasts now
i guess it's like a growing up i don't
know and that's organic because i'm just
doing what i like
because i can still be studying [ __ ]
[ __ ] rap music and trying to [ __ ]
be a [ __ ] 18 year old right now and
i'm [ __ ] about to be 36. you feel me
like i can't be [ __ ] jumping around
on stage like put up
when i'm 50 years old you feel me
so i'm in that transition point right
now you know
and i just really just want to like
be secure in life because rap music is
selling dope to me it's a gamble
right because you can
if you can be successful for 10 years
and be [ __ ] up
you know what i'm saying like right now
like i'm good right now [ __ ] 36 years
old but
46 i could be [ __ ] up
you feel what i'm saying
[ __ ] yourself from which way
financially
and i'm not trying to be [ __ ] up in 10
years in no type of way
like
i came in because people look at it like
and then that's the second call to it
where you see these [ __ ] flying
private jets and
having the biggest i'm saying making you
know what i'm saying like
if they [ __ ]
with not even a half of the [ __ ] that
you put into what you do
you get what i'm saying
but that [ __ ] only lasts for a minute
you know like i said i wanted a career
out of it i didn't want to [ __ ]
fly by night [ __ ] rap
[ __ ] one hit wonder type of [ __ ]
you know
and i'm building a natural fan base and
i'm real humble and i'm real [ __ ]
appreciative of what i have
but i just know
the
state of music
that [ __ ]
the genre of music that i do is not
really like
it's nuts like i can't really like
look at it like and like it's not
insurance for me i can't say and i can't
trust it that's what i'm gonna say
i can't trust it at this point you know
it's like selling dope to me and always
look at it like that which i kind of
love like because there's nothing like
having your back against the wall
and that's what probably makes me
produce the best [ __ ] and that's what
probably make me
have like
because i is i know like any give every
project could be over for me one trash
album and then it's over i'm back to
figuring it out i might be buying some
weed going back and trying to buy some
pounds that we eat but here's the beauty
you're going back
into this okay let's talk about
it
what's the name of that girl that's
saying that tom diner
she also sang that song my name is luca
i live on the second floor i'm just
giving you an example this moment okay
this one was no ball of fire what was
that again though what was the name of
what you made that song tom's diner tom
diner
yeah that was that was like a big deal
okay when i was looking to take a girl
like her for example suzanne vega
suzanne vegas yeah vega had two [ __ ]
big commercial hits
tom's dying i don't know when tom's
diner came out but that was a commercial
hit that
suzanne vega
still held on 87.
that's 34. that's what i love but what's
he doing that's what i'm saying okay so
that's 30 years so it's to the point
that's what i'm saying it's at a of
playing my life where i want to look at
it like
i could be able to do this i wanted to
be able to do rap music and i want to
make rap music just because i love doing
it and not and i'm a fan and i want to
have fun and i want to
make music for the people that's when
you make the people's fans that like
what i do i want to make music for them
and like that [ __ ] but it has become so
expensive that i don't even know if i
can afford it anymore
let's say that you know what i'm saying
it has become so expensive that i don't
even know if i can afford it no more
you know so
to make the time music that i want to
make and then the type of music that's
popular is
don't even
cost happiness that i'm trying to make
so
it's almost like a losing game already
before i even started playing
you feel me so it's like
selling dope it's like being a hustler
which i love in some sense because it's
like being where i'm from detroit
if i was like some like
like i've been doing what i'm doing for
a long [ __ ] time and been real like
making good money and being successful
in that sense
but
if i was like it's rappers that don't
even have like a quarter of what i have
and they go through way more trouble
just because they way more popular
because like they hot like with police
so let's say fans of the police
i'm still being able to make money and
kick my feet up and hang out with my
cats and [ __ ] permanent heels and to
have to worry about nobody trying to
even worry about where i live at and
even be weird with me like i can go out
every day and people don't say [ __ ] to
me and don't [ __ ] with me
only time people [ __ ] me is when i go
to big cities when i go to new york when
i go to la
you might like just big cities that's
when i get recognized and people like oh
danny brown [ __ ] but when i'm in detroit
when i'm at home i'm at [ __ ] the
grocery [ __ ] they hate to see
me almost type of [ __ ] he's like what
the [ __ ] you doing here if a person know
who i am they hate to see me that's how
michigan is that's how detroit is and
you live in detroit full-time i live in
farmington hills well i probably
shouldn't say that
i live in the suburbs of detroit we live
in detroit full-time so you fly a lot
all the time that's why i move closer to
the airport
so about yeah
so you go back in the studio soon i mean
the studio is in my house
with me i [ __ ]
i'd rather go back in the studio to be
recording lines for some
cartoon tv show or something you know
i'm saying didn't have them but
with me
as far as making songs i can't really
count it
like it just really happens organic
like i just get music i get beats and i
might get bored one night or if i'm
working on an app i'm working on a
project i have i know to put these beats
on every night probably like any like a
comedian probably sit down i want to
write jokes every night
i know i got to sit down and write album
you know i got to write these songs but
me i was as in adderall adderall is my
[ __ ] so i take adderall
and sit down and probably smoke a hound
should we [ __ ] pray about two
cigarettes
and write like five songs
you know but then i just write probably
like
and i'll probably do this for like a
year
not even record them and then once i get
done once i feel like i've got enough
[ __ ] where i'm comfortable enough
because i like you know you know it is
when you write some [ __ ] and it's so
good you just memorize it like you in
the shower you just taking a shower and
you ain't even recorded this like i
don't know for you like you ain't even
say this joke yet probably like you
ain't even did this bit
but it's so good to you already to
yourself you just already saying it to
yourself and i have a song in my head
and i'm already proven to that [ __ ] like
damn it's gonna be lit
so i gotta record and that's how i know
when to record that song and put that
[ __ ] up
so when you have the lyrics down you
already know you got the lyrics
where's the beat come from you boy yeah
your homies just you just gotta eat some
random yeah
and you can't even i don't i don't start
till i get a beat but i don't even start
writing a song until i get a hook
right hooks is the number one thing
like people don't really really i mean
that's the money maker you can't really
you can't really be a successful
musician
writing wise if you can't even write
hooks
and you can be the best rapper in the
[ __ ] world if you can't write a good
the worst rappers have the best looks at
this point what is hooking me the most
successful i mean the chorus okay the
chorus
i mean if you could just write choruses
and rap music like that's all that
matters now
you don't even have to be like a great
lyricist you don't have to be the best
chorus of all time
i love it when you call me big papa that
was amazing
damn that is a
great question [ __ ] uncle joey what
is the best [ __ ] chorus and rap music
of all time
and you know what you know what i would
say to be on some rap music [ __ ] the
best rap chorus probably wasn't even rap
it was just some [ __ ] that was scratched
or wasn't a chorus like just being that
real like the best rap chorus in this
[ __ ] pray with jay-z i don't
need a hook for this [ __ ]
like you know
that's what the hook was
i don't need a hug for this
[ __ ] and then he went back again
so something like that i would probably
say was the best chorus when joey says
he would go crazy when he'd hear black
sabbath if you hear jay-z going i'm
ready to hook for this [ __ ] no my go
crazy like and go crazy for me music
it's like
like i'm real like i like
like
i want [ __ ] to like i want like rap
music i want to make like one do bad
[ __ ]
like rap music i post the one i [ __ ]
feel like i want to murder you like the
first time i heard cheap keep
like you get what i'm saying like i
wonder like if rap music doesn't scare
me if it doesn't feel like i don't post
it like i don't feel like this is not
good like it's not good then
you feel what i'm saying like
it's not
nothing that supposed to be on the radio
it's not anything that supposed to be
cool with your grandma
and be able to play that [ __ ] picnics
and [ __ ]
the rap music is supposed to be some
[ __ ] that she supposed to be like oh the
[ __ ]
no
that [ __ ] is only supposed to be listen
to your headphones in your basement your
personal time like the [ __ ] this person
is saying like you listen to those
really too short records like freaky
tails like you can't even play that [ __ ]
out loud right now and not feel
comfortable
like so how was he playing that [ __ ]
back in the day and being comfortable
like
the 80s is crazy like growing up in the
80s was crazy in some sense that's why
i'm
like when you be talking about the 70s
and [ __ ] like i really like just like
really wish i was like a part of that
world like i wish i was like the 77 like
the best decade
ever first time i heard that
was when i was locked up
and it was the the third spot i went to
which was
primarily black
and i said this on
burke chrysler's podcast i go
but christchurch if you think black
people are talking movie theaters
wait till you go to county jail and
spend the night you don't know nothing
they got it rapping brothers
that they rap in prison at night
i just died because if you don't listen
to bad right deeper than that like uncle
joey like i had a i had a monkey
that the thing was oh my god
do you know you could take a garbage bag
and like wrap it over your toilet and
then you know you flush all the water
out your toilet and you just put your
ear to the bowl and then just yell down
a bowl and there's other [ __ ]
they did that and then now you talking
with them like that was like internet
chat lines and comments
i
like he woke up they call it flesh in
the talk like they were flushed like bro
he hit your plastic bag knock all the
water out you ain't your bunk i'm in the
top trying to go to sleep and you're
having a conversation this [ __ ]
gotta flush the water off the boat now
he got his head at the boat trying to
talk to what's up what's up dog yo
yo what's up the next thing you got
somebody flushed a ball right back
you got your face on that [ __ ] like
this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] night like
you on skype like they escaping every
night and you might come across some
[ __ ] every night and i wake up this
[ __ ] might be doing some weird [ __ ]
won't they see them tomorrow and won't
they get to hang out in the morning
how are you in jail where i don't know
doesn't matter
lee they
and the funeral parlor is across the
street i'm just saying like they would
yell from the sounds oh yeah no that was
awesome brothers we yo yo toray yo what
up what up where you at yo toray where
you from i'm down for mayton washington
you got a cousin named tina i asked him
that's working oh [ __ ] i like one scene
i think one thing i learned about jail
and was probably like the best thing
it exposes whoever you are
like if you really if you if you tough
like that like you tough like that if
you're a bitch-ass [ __ ] like you a
[ __ ] if you are [ __ ] like you're a [ __ ]
like if you like whatever you are and
like you can fake in the real world
but once you go behind them walls like
as a man like we gonna find like [ __ ]
like we already
what are you like you know what i'm
saying you really find yourself i don't
know like like i can't
i don't want to say that like it's like
some type of retreat
if you go there and you make it out like
and you can figure it out like it really
is true right but you find yourself in
that [ __ ] you really figured out
who you are you're like no i'm not like
these [ __ ] like i watch a [ __ ]
get raped through the sale oh god
but [ __ ] had a job at me like a
registry job like if you know cause you
know [ __ ] come from upstate
and they gotta come to the county to go
to
jail
and he had to get a [ __ ] the cheese
sandwich the [ __ ] grabbed him through
the sale like the [ __ ] he gave him a
sandwich
knocked him out
i don't know how but he knocked them out
some type of way and was [ __ ] this
[ __ ] through the sail like he in his
cell this thing on the outside what
would you take decorated cheese sandwich
and this is county jail this same prison
this ain't going upstate this [ __ ]
county like okay
again [ __ ] [ __ ] don't talk look here
if i if if i ever had to go there
could i could i just talk no the worst
thing i had let me tell you the worst
thing i dealt with in jail
like that because i work registry
tonight i'm gonna put this [ __ ] out
there cause it needs to be put out there
oh [ __ ]
i need to be put out there this is a
story that need to be told
last one
this is the story they need to be told
the real ones this is the story they
need to be told and danny brown like
like some real [ __ ] like get your
recorders ready like real [ __ ] so look
i'm working like i said i'm in the
county i'm working registry it's to the
point i got the [ __ ] police
officers on my line like all the [ __ ]
ceos they love me i don't even eat the
jail food no more joey they bring me
burger king
i'm [ __ ] taking subway
sandwiches up to my bunk like i'm living
that type of life in county jail you
feel what i'm saying like the [ __ ]
police i'm like teacher's pet the
[ __ ] police love me in this brother
but you don't say it so i get but i get
out of cigarettes you know what i'm
saying i'm the [ __ ] cause i work
registry that's the point of registry so
but all the people before me was sell
cigarettes i smoked so much cigarettes
and i'm getting people sending me money
like my homies from like i said the
homies i was hustling for they sending
me money so i don't need to even
need to sell cigarettes to make money in
jail for commissary because i always got
full commissary books like uh you know
what i'm saying so i wasn't tripping on
making money like that so i just smoked
cigarettes so the whole jail hated me i
really flipped the whole jail when homie
gave me his job and left he was selling
cigarettes he left out and showed me
that he had like 5 000. like you guys
should make five racks in like
eight months he was like that for a year
too like i mean five racks in eight
months like you better make money while
you locked up and leave home with some
money which i wish i probably should
have did because i went home broke like
i told you i'm like my second day being
home i'm like what the [ __ ] am i gonna
do
but anyway so i was just smoking all the
cigarettes like i was the type of
[ __ ] i was going to nix floors
getting my hair braided by [ __ ]
like all type of weird [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying see i ain't forgot what
i wasn't even talking about right now
we're not even talking about where was
that we were talking [ __ ] about the star
wars
anything ever happened could i like go
to a garden to say put me in in solitary
no i want to do that lead jelly you know
what it is about jim no
it's just beer no
no be honest though it's just be
yourself just be who you are i don't
want to be anything right if you will
like i said expose you for who you is so
if you if you like not really about that
life i'm not
like like was that isn't that what
happens joey talked about it like some
kid like me just like a dui or something
and
end up in there
well that seems like the worst place
yeah i'd rather be on the negative but
you know what it is it's just that those
big states
like l.a and like i hear that [ __ ] about
texas like a [ __ ] get locked up
like a dui you get lost in the system
like [ __ ] like that you post a bit
[ __ ] you probably got out and then
you end up doing six months like you
know what i'm saying like [ __ ] like that
like i hear a story like even me
but hang on i thought i wasn't supposed
to do a year for it because now look
what we doing now
you got [ __ ] dispensaries we buy weed
for free all the i got like that for
selling weed i did eight months in my
life for selling weed you know
you can go by we for free every [ __ ]
day y'all gonna get my eight months back
every every [ __ ] state trying to
[ __ ] legalize weed
that's what i did time for
uncle joe are you out you're all right
no no i got allergies you did time for
everything else you did
see that's what i'm saying like the [ __ ]
the most [ __ ] up [ __ ] that's what
[ __ ] spot up i remember one time like
one time we got ready like i said we
used to get raided so much that we was
used to the [ __ ] we used to have a
[ __ ] ounce head on the roof so we're
going a [ __ ] roof and we had this
weed we're going very soon why aren't
the cops checking the roof
they couldn't even get up there if they
wanted to because it was a chimney so if
they were to come it was like a ladder
if there was a come so you said say it
was a [ __ ]
seven-story apartment right so if you
got to the highest floor the seventh
floor and then you saw a ladder
you go up this ladder and it's like a
lot it's like a padlock so you think
it's locked so when you push it
it feels like it's locked but it's just
us sitting on it
because they would push on it they would
get there and push on it but it was just
sitting on it you know what i'm saying
but if you went there like soon as they
raided it we would just run instantly
run to that roof open that [ __ ] up we
sit on the roof close that [ __ ] up boom
sitting on it i got a pack of cigarettes
fired up
we smoking we just wait in the sea we
look over and just see out our
neighborhood react to know if the po we
can see the bands i know if they're gone
and [ __ ] like that you know they left
but
one day we got raided right
we like [ __ ] it whatever the [ __ ] we got
rated
but they taking we getting so used to
raised well we don't give a [ __ ] no more
what do you mean you don't give a [ __ ]
i'm saying we don't give a [ __ ] so much
that we like [ __ ] it while they rain we
still just left
from the roof and just came down
and just went down through the [ __ ] and
just went out the back door like [ __ ]
and we came out the back door and then
we went to the gas station like grab
some sodas
grab some blunts or whatever the [ __ ]
and we're like walking up the block and
[ __ ]
and then we seen this little this kid on
the porch
and i was like [ __ ] it let's just uh you
know i ran and sat on the porch and the
kid name his name was little b which is
the funniest [ __ ] his name is brian but
we caught him little b this was like
2 000 [ __ ]
i don't know 2001 will it be so i met
lil b he's from oakland just the
funniest [ __ ] in the world he's telling
me about [ __ ] og kush all this type
of crazy weed that i never even heard of
in my life
but i end up liking this little kid he
only like 13 14. you know what i'm
saying
like i told you we had this spot for
like so this is like the first year of
us having a spot and us getting raided
you know what i'm saying but i met this
kid a little bit i already grabbed the
kid from whatever i told you like once
once once the spot started making money
i went back to school and started
recruiting
and i grabbed the kid which is baby jane
that's my homie so i had baby james
working with me then doom was just like
my fourth i had doomway to me so
had like two [ __ ] in the spot with me
with that
and they was like surpassed me quickly
that's how i knew i wasn't a good drug
dealer right because like all i was
doing was buying video games and like
clothes and like instantly they had like
been just in car
and houses and [ __ ]
like two weeks of them working around me
like i brought them into this [ __ ] and
then before i knew it they was like way
more successful than me and like showing
us like instantly
so i ended up meeting this kid little b
and i'm like [ __ ] it i sat on his porch
while my spot was getting ready and i
smoked the blunt of him and then i ended
up brought him into the mix
but he's little being 14. oh my god but
he turns out to be a [ __ ] psycho
like one day
like i put him in the spot and i already
put him up on game okay i'm just gonna
pass four and i'm just gonna make a long
so you know he's gonna make a long story
short but so now he already with the
[ __ ] here in the spot
and one day i just come back to the spot
that's when i knew it was like all the
way like fourth floor it's crazy like i
come back to the spot he in there
working with
us and i come back to the spot and
he like yo the [ __ ] owe me for some
money so i kidnapped him
he in the closet right now
he got a muffin crack here that owe him
20 dollars just trapped in the closet
like on some oak like we don't even trip
on [ __ ] credit like where we how we
hustle like that is like a 20 like
whatever like we like you know look go
yeah yeah you gotta give a hundred and
credit from time to time credit is what
made me like being like popular like i
didn't even had a name danny yeah my
name was daniel all the way so i started
giving out credit
the kraken started calling me danny you
like to be like danny what's up
what's up you know what i'm saying
so anyway the [ __ ] um
and he kidnapped thing and [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] in the [ __ ] closet
[ __ ] let the [ __ ] i'm like man you
can't do that you know what i'm saying
like this or not you got us a new goal
but how do you get him in the closet
i don't know as a 14 year old but we had
a gun so i feel like he's a gun you just
put him in there get in the closet yeah
he's just putting me and what's that was
it
the long story short is the [ __ ]
in the closet end up getting shot i
ain't saying who shot him
he ended up getting shot
like a week later the brothers or the
people of the brother end up coming
through and they shot our [ __ ] up
shooting at us like doing [ __ ] like
retaliation for their brother and it's
like it was a crackhead
this wasn't like and that's what [ __ ]
our spot up it wasn't that we got into
it with some street [ __ ] some real
[ __ ] some
it was us like my homie that we got some
random 14 year old from oakland
and i was like oh [ __ ] he with the [ __ ]
he might be cool working a spot he just
took it too far and kidnapped a
crackhead
but you don't know who you kidnapping
like
when
just because a [ __ ] crackhead
don't mean he don't got people
and this crack can't end up having
people that really cared to [ __ ] about
him like really like money behind like
he was just a crackhead but his family
really had [ __ ]
and they they they threw firebombs in
our spot oh my god they burnt the bishop
like i remember us it got to the point
where we started trying to go out of
town because we had so much work from us
hustling so like we got to get it up
somewhere we started trying to go to
ohio
wyoming ohio
and i remember that we went to vegas
then that [ __ ] didn't work out and
coming back and then everything was just
over
like with sudden crack like our spot was
burned down
the building was raided out like you
couldn't even like we suddenly crack on
the streets like it was over you know
what i'm saying so
she started trying to that's when we
started selling weed so it just
transferred the weed
and selling weed was selling weed to our
friends and from that that's what got me
locked up
and once i went to jail
it was like once i was in jail because i
was already started like trying to make
music and like trying to be a rapper but
like i said my friends hated me for
making trying to be a rapper
so i was always like
not really like confident in it
you people i'm saying but i just
put my best before i don't know it's
like i hadn't enough to do
i don't know
you're like rich again office and
gentlemen you have nowhere else to go
like it was like what if somebody said
this they had a point
after the [ __ ] like me putting the
pounds in the truck and all that [ __ ] i
mean one time it was like pounds no i
was like we was in arizona and i had to
like and i was like putting the balls on
the world we are putting the balls on
the truck and [ __ ]
but we had like money in the house
but then he was these mexican
[ __ ] like the one who's getting
the pounds from but like the [ __ ] that
was it was like okay it was like the
plug it was like the big homie he was
talking to my big homie and then it was
that he had his workers then my big
homie and his workers and i'm part of my
big homie workers like so i was a [ __ ]
that was just with my [ __ ] i'm his
right hand man
look at that [ __ ] plane i'm his right
hand man but i'm just putting bows on
the truck i ain't doing an extra i got a
gun i got a gun on me [ __ ] like that but
but one day just 10 000 came up missing
so i had to be one of these [ __ ] like
one of these mexican [ __ ] not speaking
english like like weird [ __ ] like
so [ __ ] trying to find where the money
is like you know what i'm saying like
and it could have went bad like but i
guess we just took the l
just to be like whatever but
i knew that i mean that was me after
jail though i'm like but i'm still
putting myself in these situations
because this is my big homie that's
supporting my life like put my money in
my pocket but he's giving me the gun and
uh a [ __ ] beat him for 10 racks
and now i got so i'm supposed to shoot
the [ __ ] you get what i'm saying like i
got a plan like i'm already like i'm
already playing there like [ __ ] it i'm
about to shoot this [ __ ] and then just
jump out the window and then
i gotta figure it out i'm in [ __ ]
phoenix arizona
but why the [ __ ] i probably put myself
through this [ __ ] after
spending eight months in the counter
all the money i was making was going
into my rap career
for fun
i did the same thing i did the same
thing i didn't load
i was treading on a thin [ __ ]
line you know what i'm saying big
difference but
because that's the thing i want to
actually like nobody comes out of jail
and sticks with the body you stay so
strong and just stick to the script me
yeah no no no no
where's the pen you know me i'm a econ
mage i like graphs
so there's no misunderstandings you
understand me i like grass
so let's pretend
i got out of
i got out of
[Music]
i guess
all right
i got up right here
so was four
and three seven months i stayed at that
[ __ ] camp okay
then they shipped me to a halfway house
now let's say i got to the halfway house
monday
at 3 p.m
if you want me to lie to you i could
tell you a bunch of lies and [ __ ]
if i got to the halfway house monday at
3 p.m
you got like a three day
period in the house where you got to do
paperwork and learn to buy laws and
clean your room and mop the hallways
then that's like the three days
they give you paperwork and they verify
all the places that you know in the
area [ __ ]
by thursday they let me out in the
afternoon
by thursday afternoon i already did coke
what time did you leave like noon
let's say i got to the halfway house
monday right at three in the afternoon
i played the game one day okay how are
you doing it's over the game too
see that's my whole thing with me like i
played the game wednesday evening i told
you now like i told you like blow right
now is so trash no no no it's i'm just
saying that
how long did it take me to break the law
like it took me three days and that's
when i started slinging it but it wasn't
even three days because you were you
yeah the whole time i couldn't think
about it then it was then i started
slinging it while living at the halfway
house and loan sharking rent money plus
my friend was sending me watches
from new jersey which fell off a bus
there you know i was a one-man wrecking
crew
that was under the radar like the only
worst thing i ever did there was i
wanted to see you the college and across
the street from the college there was
like a student center and one day i
walked in then there was this [ __ ]
you don't even want to listen
there was this thing of watches
you know when i was in high school i
stole a whole thing of gold chains one
time
it was the same difference they put a
thing on watches that spins around i
just picked this [ __ ] the old
ladies looked at me like
walked out of that
[ __ ] like
what the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with joy bananas
bro all those places i stole everything
oh my god i did everything that was low
radar
in your face i remember regretting the
prime minister of the scene of the [ __ ]
of rollywood listen man
just grab that [ __ ] you can walk out
you're getting caught with two but i
know it's i know it's possible because
you get caught with two ounces of coke
that's a wrap and you getting caught
with three stolen pens
that assumedly you stole because
remember there was no cameras in these
days
there was no role to videotape like
there is now
go to the hallway see if he walked by
if he was getting chased by davey brown
you know uh
you know you don't [ __ ] there was
none of that [ __ ]
listen i'm gonna be in 1985.
this is how crazy and danny will tell
you
this is the mind
i got 10 g's in the bank
i got eight g's in my pocket maybe a
thousand hundreds and the rest and
twenties
so i walk by this radio shack every
[ __ ] day
oh my god i go to the mall every day
and every day i walk past this radio
shack and there's not a it's not a dvd
player what came before the dvd player
it's v8 just like this
that's that that laser laser just cuz i
remember my uncle look i had look that's
why i laughed when you said radio shack
i had an uncle that was addicted to
crack he would break into every radio
show oh my god it was so much he was on
the news he like caused radio shack
millions like it was the radio shack
band he got caught up in the [ __ ] he did
like eight years of breaking in radio
shacks like he literally
destroyed every radio shack in detroit
or in michigan in that area of detroit
like he would like just
he would saw the back the the the the
back of the store like i don't what you
call like break i don't know
single-handedly across the country i'm
driving my i would rob a different ship
from give me the paperwork no wonder i'm
out of business now dog i would rob
different [ __ ] in different cities and
bring them to a different radio shack
and get the money back
for compute this before you went beep
now when you go beep it tells you where
the story came from what time it got
there what market it was shipped on
where it was made who the inspector was
yeah who put that [ __ ] alarm clock
together how's that one for you lisa i
had
now they don't know dick all they know
is you're paying 12.99
they give you a receipt back then and
you went home and nobody do nothing as
long as i had the store name and the
date and it's the same paperwork as
their receipt
that's all they give a french means [ __ ]
about
how you feeling lisa i see you looking
yeah you're going to change he went
through a couple changes i want to look
i i
i said i was came in respecting the star
too i i i ain't that i thought i might i
thought no you look good you did good
plus the heading yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] cigars
yeah i gotta religious facetiming no we
we did good tonight lee did very good
we ate like two thousand milligrams of
western fluid look at him jesus christ
i'm with my uncle joey that's right tell
them i'm sending them my love right here
let me show you
what up champion uncle joey
that's right what's up my love is over
let me read the sad and we'll get the
hell out of here i can't believe you
came on the podcast man man i love it
man
if it wasn't for you man i don't know
like
the last like year like me being on my
last tour like i remember just waking up
every morning and watching your [ __ ]
morning smokes and i'll be hitting my
tutu
what's in your [ __ ] you just that would
inspire me to do my show that night
every night like [ __ ] that go out there
and slang dick [ __ ] with you you're
gonna be saying that every night i'll be
like [ __ ] that
and then every night i would like i
would no matter how i felt like i could
watch you maybe i could watch you on
periscope in the morning and you say
what you gotta i could go out and do my
show every night no matter and that got
me through my last [ __ ] tour i swear
i love you i know there was something
about you i like this [ __ ] lee how you
feeling i'm feeling
good i'm good i'm good i feel like i
might have to go out to dinner
that was cheap where you guys going
anyway good
no look at you like a [ __ ] duck
what are you doing you want a snack but
you can't find it all you can find is
junk food
you rely on your self-control and you
try to resist the temptation like right
now my wife's got
[ __ ] girl scout cookies in the
cabinet good luck
please you eat the junk food
start snacking healthy with nature box
nature box makes snacks would actually
taste great and are better for you
created with high quality ingredients
that are free-form artificial colors
flavors sweeteners so you can feel great
about snacking my personal favorite are
the plantain chips
i like the uh the chocolate
chocolate nom noms i still got half a
bag at the house i mean those are my
favorite nature buck oh and i like the
the uh salt and pepper lentils that
delicious sriracha cashews sriracha
cashews are off the chain
naturebox recently made their service
even better now you can order as much as
you want as often as you want with no
minimum purchase required when you can
and you can cancel
anytime it's simple go to naturebox.com
and check out their snack catalog
there are over 100 snacks to choose from
and they're constantly adding delicious
new snacks choose the snacks you want
and they'll deliver them right to your
door do me a favor right now you'll save
even more nature box is offering our
fans right now people listen to the
church
50 off your first order when you go to
naturebox.com
joey you smoke 90 numbers you go to
naturebox.com
pick the snacks
the flavors the plantain chips
the non-nons
the black and salt and pepper lentils
you lose your [ __ ] mind you
understand me you're gonna innate what
are you gonna do eat all the other junk
that's out there you're gonna look like
uncle joey when you're 28 hell no eat
stuff that's healthy go to naturebox.com
right now
i'm telling you you're going to get 50
percent off your first order go to
naturebox.com slash drop
joey oh [ __ ]
right now that's naturebox.com
jelly oh [ __ ]
50 off your first order again
eat healthy brother it's a new year you
want to look sharp
you want if the sum is coming you want
to put the bikini on you know what i'm
saying go to naturebox.com right now and
press in jelly boom get 50 off your
first order who do you guys think you're
messing with on a monday tuesday morning
huh
not joey banana that's right baby boy
let's pretend you're hiring do you know
where you want to post your job to find
the best candidate no you don't
posting your job in one place
isn't enough to find quality candidates
that's why
if you want the perfect hire you need to
post your job on all the top job sites
and now you can with
ziprecruiter.com you can post your job
to 200 plus sites
including social media networks like
facebook and twitter all with a single
click
find candidates in any city industry
nationwide
just post once and watch your qualified
candidates
rolling the zip recruiters easy to use
interface no juggling emails no calls to
your office
quickly screen candidates rate them and
hire the right person
fast
find out today why zip recruiter has
been used by fortune 100 companies and
thousands of small and medium-sized
businesses and right now today my
listeners can post jobs on ziprecruiter
for free
by going to ziprecruiter.com
church oh
that's ziprecruit.com
that's right one more time for free go
to ziprecord.com
slash church
and you can put
your
posts for free that's it just like that
all right i want to thank zip recruiter
one more time
and i want to thank my people over there
at nature box with the best snacks out
there but i want to thank my brother
from a different mother mr danny brown
thank you man some love what else you
swear like on it oh that's right
honor.com don't forget temp is set off
delivered to your house sorry about that
db drop it on them no thanks no i'm just
saying like man you know like you were
like a big inspiration with me like man
i just wanna like you know me like i
feel like i'm old at being 36
like if i could be as cool as you are at
[ __ ] 54 years old i'm trying but i
feel like i made it
i could just do it
you got yourself out of the hard part
yeah that's it now you're out of the
woods now you can be whatever you want
to be i mean and out of her party just
sustaining i said maintaining and you
know like you said just stay in the flow
like no no jungle sometimes make me
wonder
i know that's why i try to tell you the
history of the afro-cuban
yeah no day one i'm definitely going to
all i've ever told you is to stay black
me i stay black every day
that's all i ever try to do i wake up in
the morning i try to stay black ask lisa
if i'm not the blackest cuban he knows i
don't change any day of the week he
wants to go eat vietnamese food no i
wish he gets hit by a [ __ ] food truck
you know me dog all that [ __ ] we don't
know
i was not even lizardman
the only thing he is more than black is
he's jewish he's like this week he went
they more junk oh my god then he went
back sunday again
about like when i jumped
like that's the way i know how [ __ ] up
like why do i like fried chicken
gizzards like but i'm from my
neighborhood like my neighborhood had
like a spot that that was like his sting
like it sold fried chicken my neighbor
didn't have that like fried chicken
gizzards and fried chicken livers and
that was like the thing like you can go
order other food from i mean you can buy
chicken like or like you know like
whatever but but
it's unfair with joey because he just
he he sticks with the first asian sauce
raised
here he sticks with well do you would
you mess with anyone other than mexican
and cuban
do you do you have any other i like
hispanic food that you eat not really
god damn it yeah what else i'm trying to
think filipino food is [ __ ] up
they like take like all their words like
like cheap as [ __ ] but they didn't
everything is great with the philippines
after the pigeon comes up
that's where the party is that's not
gonna pay the tab
we all give hugs to each other once i
see the pigeon feed on the table you
gotta go
i love you [ __ ] see you
wednesday night
i love you brother stay black and
beautiful thank you very much family
thank you
everything
you